monsieur le président
bien chers collègues la séance est
reprise
la parole l'état Maryse Carrère pour une
mise au point au sujet d'un vote
le président lors du scrutin numéro 166
portant sur les amendements numéro 2015
et 21 et 2109 pardon notre collègue
Henri Cabanel souhaitait voter contre je
vous remercie
remarquable 65% de nos concitoyens et
concitoyens sont favorables à une grève
reconductible l'apocalypse a annoncé par
Monsieur Veyron ne fait pas peur tout
comme votre invraisemblable interview
dans le Parisien je parle de là du
ministre du socle au cours de laquelle
il a affirmé présenté à notre assemblée
une réforme de gauche
cela n'a pas trompé le peuple de même
300 défilés sont organisés dans le pays
un record depuis le début de la
mobilisation alors monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues allez-vous entendre
cette levée de masse entendez-vous ce
peuple qui débourre au métropole exprime
au-delà du texte même une aspiration
profonde à la justice sociale à
l'égalité à la solidarité monsieur le
ministre de nombreux membres du
gouvernement ont cru bon annoncé le
déluge demain vous dénoncez le blocage
la mise en danger de l'économie je vous
le dis solennellement c'est vous qui
êtes responsable du chaos c'est vous qui
pénalisez la population en leur imposant
de la souffrance au travail deux années
supplémentaires et en leur volant deux
années de retraite en bonne santé donc
n'ayez aucune hésitation
messieurs les ministres mais vous êtes
seul là pour l'instant monsieur Attal si
vous voulez apaiser vous consacrer aux
urgences sociales climatiques je vous le
dis sincèrement retir er ce projet
retirer le de la séance dès maintenant
merci merci madame la Présidente acte
est donnée de votre rappel au règlement
monsieur le ministre
non très rapidement monsieur le
Président pour répondre à la présidente
assassy aussi rapidement oui j'ai
dénoncé ce week-end au moment du Salon
de l'Agriculture j'étais interrogé sur
le sujet un certain nombre de
déclarations et certaines déclarations
de responsable politique qui ont appelé
je cite à mettre l'économie française à
genoux et ce que j'ai répondu et je
l'assume
à genoux c'est le terme qui a été
employé si si et ce que je dis c'est que
quand on dit qu'on va mettre l'économie
française à genoux ce sont des usines ce
sont des travailleurs ce sont des
Français qui travaillent ce que j'ai dit
ensuite c'est que quand il y a des
blocages la réalité c'est que ce sont
souvent les plus modestes et les plus
fragiles qui sont les premiers impactés
par les blocages
et que comme je l'ai dit l'école blanc
comme on dit l'école blanche en général
ils peuvent télétravailler ils peuvent
aller travailler à vélo parce qu'ils
habitent à côté de leur travail pas les
travailleurs les plus modestes et les
plus fragiles qui doivent se lever
prendre le métro prendre leur voiture
pour aller travailler c'est le premier
point deuxième point madame assassy je
vous ai entendu utiliser les sondages
comme argument c'est un beau débat de
savoir si les sondages doivent être la
boussole dans les votes et les décisions
que nous prenons moi je considère que ça
n'est pas le cas mais si vous considérez
que les sondages sont à ce point une
boussole pourquoi vous êtes-vous opposé
à la suppression des régimes spéciaux à
laquelle 80% des Français sont
favorables dans les mêmes sondages
par cohérence vous auriez dû voter en
faveur de la suppression des régimes
spéciaux c'est donc bien que les
sondages ne sont pas la seule et unique
boussole qu'il faut suivre au moment des
votes sinon vous auriez voté
différemment
bien nous allons donc reprendre la
discussion
c'était juste un rappel aux règlements
avec une réaction du ministre il n'y a
pas de débat sur ce rappel au règlement
nous reprenons la discussion du projet
de loi mais nous allons pouvoir
continuer à débattre je pense toute
l'après-midi nous reprenons la
discussion du projet de loi de
financement rectificatif de la sécurité
sociale pour 2023 dans la discussion des
articles nous sommes parvenus à la
présentation de l'amendement
tendin pendant à insérer un article
additionnel après l'article 2
donc cet amendement le 4281 est présenté
par Monsieur Bocquet oui merci monsieur
le Président donc il apparaît de plus en
plus clairement qu'il y ait un consensus
naissant entre la majorité sénatoriale
et le gouvernement pour aller
progressivement dans ce pays vers un
système de retraite par capitalisation
on en connaît tous les risques
par exemple pour atteindre une pension
de retraite équivalente à 75% du dernier
bulletin de salaire il faudrait placer
deux mois de salaire chaque année sans
aucune garantie de restitution parce
qu'on connaît les risques liés à la
spéculation en bourse comme c'est bien
entendu le cas dans le cadre de la
capitalisation en 2021 avec le système
par répartition le montant cotisé est de
10 euros par mois pour obtenir ses
droits à la retraite le remplacement des
cotisations vers l'impôt fait basculer
la protection sociale d'un système
solidaire où chacun participe selon ses
moyens et reçoit en fonction de ses
besoins à un système d'assistance
minimale financé par l'État qui pousse
ceux qui en ont les moyens
va se tourner donc vers un système
d'assurance privé
s'attaquer ainsi aux cotisations
sociales c'est fermé les yeux sur
l'emprise grandissante des actionnaires
sur la valeur ajoutée dans notre
économie en effet la part de la valeur
ajoutée consacrée aux dividendes à
presque triplés ces 20 dernières années
en revanche elle dessinait la
rémunération du travail à diminuer
concrètement les salaires et donc les
cotisations qui sont rattachées n'ont
pas suivi la flambée des profits et on
sait que pour la capitalisation les
marchés financiers Piaf d'un patients
cette sous-rémération du travail est une
source d'explosion des inégalités
économiques et sociales rendez-vous
compte s'il a pas des dividendes versées
aux actionnaires du CAC 40 en 2016 avait
été maintenu au taux de 2009 ces
entreprises auraient pu accorder 2000
euros à leurs salariés les cotisations
sociales auraient été beaucoup plus
importantes et la question du
financement de la retraite en bonne
partie réglée je vous remercie
merci
Madame la rapporteur
ah pardon excusez-moi excusez-moi on est
dans une discussion commune je reprenais
donc on va continuer à
donc l'amendement 4280 monsieur gay
faut que je me remette dans le rythme
excusez-moi
monsieur
allez-y monsieur gay merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre et chers
collègues d'ailleurs c'est le Ministre
ce qu'on est au Parlement pour débattre
et pour réagir aussi tranquillement
quand on met le pays à l'arrêt c'est à
dire en grève puisque ce sont les
travailleurs et les travailleuses qui
créent la richesse et lorsqu'ils ne sont
pas au travail en grève le pays est à
l'arrêt et personne je ne crois sur ces
bancs ou dans le pays a décidé de mettre
le pays à genoux mais le pays à l'arrêt
dans un rapport de force avec vous
jusqu'au retrait de cette réforme et je
me permets monsieur le ministre de dire
qu'il ne faut pas opposer les Françaises
et les Français entre eux parce que
demain défileront les salariés de la
RATP les salariés des i.g comme dont
vous avez décidé la suppression des
régimes et aussi des salariés du public
et du privé juste sur une question sur
le ministre sur lequel vous avez déjà
répondu mais je voudrais avoir votre
éclaircissement sur ce point non je
parle pas de là de la question que je
vais venir vous poser là si nous venions
adopter donc des exonérations de
cotisations est-ce que l'État est
combien de temps l'état viendrait
évidemment continuer à
allez allez comment je cherche le terme
à les compenser merci monsieur le
ministre c'est ça la question qui nous
est posée parce que d'ailleurs des
chercheurs je les cite car bourse et
chochard on dit je les cite un certain
nombre d'exemptions d'assiettes de
banlieue à compensation par le budget de
l'État en effet ces dispositifs pour la
plupart ont été instaurés avant le 13
août 94 or l'obligation de compensation
ne porte que sur les mesures créées
après le 13 août 2014 et donc il n'y
aurait pas d'obligation donc je voudrais
bien avoir votre éclaircissement sur ce
sujet je vous remercie monsieur le
Président merci Monsieur et ensuite le
4280 madame a poursuit
4279 avant alors donc c'est Madame limon
un déplafonnement des cotisations en
proposant un des plafonnement qui ne
doivent pas être inférieures à 2,39 pour
les salariés et 4-19 pour les employeurs
premièrement pour les salariés ça ne
touchera pas les salariés dont le revenu
mensuel est inférieur à 366 euros
ne touche pas les salariés les plus
modestes quant à la cotisation employeur
elle elle est quand même très
supportable par les entreprises d'autant
plus que elle contribue quand même
davantage à la redistribution car ce
système de plafonnement est plutôt un
amortisseur à toute esprit de
redistribution
mais par ailleurs monsieur le ministre
vous et votre gouvernement vous répétez
à l'envie nous avons alléger les
cotisations sociales donc ça a permis de
créer des emplois
je voudrais bien savoir sur quelle base
d'analyse de relation de la cause à
effet vous pouvez nous dire ce genre de
choses car quand avait été étudié
l'analyse de l'exonération équivalente
cice le commissaire la Commission et le
comité qui avait dû analyser l'impact
sur l'emploi s'était rendu compte qu'il
était extrêmement modeste parce que la
corrélation ne fait pas la cause il y a
eu un élément une élévation de la
température mondiale avec l'effet de
serre donc ça a créé des emplois puisque
simultanément on a créé des emplois non
essayez donnez-nous les éléments et les
études qui expliquent qu'il y a une
réelle cause à effet
si Madame linman le 4278 madame apource
78 maintenant on vient de présenter le
4279 merci
excusez-nous oui l'amendement donc
effectivement
4278 une nouvelle fois a-t-elle sizyme
monsieur le ministre nous allons tenter
de vous convaincre d'augmenter les
cotisations sociales pour certaines
catégories afin de financer non
seulement l'équilibre du régime de
retraite existant mais aussi de
permettre de revenir à la retraite à 60
ans en fixant un minimum de retraite
décent garanti à l'ensemble de nos
compatriotes bien entendu cette
perspective fait pousser des cris
d'orfray à tous les défenseurs du
orthodoxie libéral je l'entends oui nous
sommes convaincus qu'il existe des
moyens de financer un autre choix de
société un choix de justice sociale et
d'épanouissement humain au terme d'une
carrière professionnelle et surtout ne
nous dit pas que ce choix a été validé
par les élections de 2022 on sait dans
quel contexte c'était l'élection est
intervenue on s'est contre qui monsieur
le Président de la République a été élu
la légitimité proviendrait-elle de
l'alliance de mariage contraint entre le
gouvernement de Monsieur Macron et les
républicains ici c'est à douter lorsque
l'on connaît le score de accompagné avec
son présidentielle et au législatives
oui il existe une alternative à votre
projet et des financements existent
comme nous vous le démontrons en
entreprise avec l'ensemble des groupes
de gauche durant ce débat le vrai dessin
des auteurs de ce projet et de l'ordre
relève d'une autre alternative on l'a
évoqué dans j'ai déjà vous prétendez
défendre le régime par répartition avec
cette réforme mes en fait vous poussez
nos concitoyens progressivement ceux qui
le peuvent en tout cas vers le régime
par capitalisation merci
le 4277 madame Cohen
merci monsieur le Président à l'occasion
de la présentation de cet amendement je
souhaite revenir une nouvelle fois sur
l'enjeu fondamental de notre débat notre
système de retraite va-t-il échapper à
la solidarité pour devenir une
formidable vente pour les fonds de
pension et autres assureurs privés
puisque vous avez réussi à mettre un par
voie d'amendement un rapport sur la
capitalisation si la capitalisation
demeure minoritaire en France et le
progrès considérablement les produits de
retraite complémentaire comptait fin
14,5 millions d'adhérence soit 4,5
millions de plus en disant le montant
total placé en épargne retraite est
passé de 219 milliards d'euros fin 2016
à 280 milliards en mars 2020 bien sûr en
7,6 milliards d'euros ont été versés au
titre de contrat de retraite
complémentaire contre 338 milliards dans
le cadre du régime par répartition mais
cette part est amené à progresser de
manière très rapide du fait de la
signature en grand nombre par des jeunes
salariés de contrats de capitalisation
en 2021 20 milliards d'euros d'épargne
retraite ont été collectés ces 27% de
plus qu'en 2021 et 6 fois plus que 10
ans auparavant cela a été déjà dit la
raison est simple a peur de l'avenir
l'incertitude engendrée par les réformes
successives le recul de l'âge du départ
l'allongement des durées de cotisations
qui poussent les plus jeunes vers la
capitalisation il suffit d'avoir des
enfants qui démarrent leur vie
professionnelle connaître des jeunes
dans cette même situation pour
comprendre cette angoisse qui pousse un
sauf qui peut marquer par
l'individualisme notons également que ce
seront surtout les salariés des grandes
entreprises et les contribuables les
plus aisés qui pourront opérer ce
sauvetage bien aléatoire car tributaire
des évolutions des marchés financiers je
vous remercie mais le bruit de fond est
quand même assez gênant
4276 monsieur gay
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues les per sur
lesquels les placements explosent
aujourd'hui furent créés par la loi
pacte votée lors du premier quinquennat
d'Emmanuel Macron il a été lancé en
octobre 2019 ce nouveau per a remplacé
les anciens produits d'épargne retraite
individuel ou collectif il s'agissait
tout le monde s'en rappelle des
dispositifs madeleins préfont PERP ou
PERCO ces derniers outils financiers ne
sont plus commercialisés depuis 2020
depuis le lancement la nouvelle formule
un doublement des publicités a été
constaté pour appeler à souscription il
est évident que la perspective d'un
recul de l'âge de la retraite jugé
parfois impossible à atteindre pousse à
cet investissement nous savons toutes et
tous ici que des jeunes récemment
rentrés sur le marché du travail après
des études plus ou moins longues nous
pourrons pas espérer un taux plein avant
68 69 voir 70 ans il faut donc trouver
coûte que c'est nouveau moyen pour
permettre de partir à la retraite à un
HD 100 en bonne santé coûte que coûte
pour les travailleuses et travailleurs
concernés salariés ou libéraux mais
aussi coucou coûte pour la société car
ce développement considérable des
assurances privées se fait bien entendu
au détriment de la solidarité au cœur du
système de répartition principe de
solidarité fondée sur les cotisations
sociales pourtant le risque est grand
car chacune et chacun sait que les
placements financiers sont incertains il
suffit de se remémorer la crise des
subprimes aux États-Unis entraînant un
crack mondial et la disparition du jour
au lendemain pour les Américains de leur
épargne capitalisée le PER c'est aussi
une arme terrible contre la solidarité
du fait du plafond très élevé de
déduction fiscale et tout le monde sait
ici que les couches populaires ne
pourront pas la peindre je vous remercie
monsieur le président
merci Monsieur gay le 4275 madame
brûlant
merci monsieur le Président avec ses
amendements nous proposons en effet
d'augmenter le taux de cotisation
sociale des plafonnés à l'assurance
vieillesse sur les revenus supérieurs au
plafond de la sécurité sociale hier il y
a eu dans cette hémicycle un débat
nourri et assez éclairant me semble-t-il
sur la retraite par capitalisation que
certains seraient impatient de voir
advenir et plusieurs d'entre vous nous
ont expliqué à cette occasion que il
serait dommage de notre part de ne pas
suivre un mouvement qui était déjà
enclenché c'est vrai on doit vous
l'accorder et mes collègues viennent de
donner un certain nombre d'exemples il y
a des salariés qui ont choisi ou en tout
cas qui sont contraints d'aller vers des
outils et des instruments financiers
pour s'assurer une retraite parce que
réforme après réformes les pensions
diminuent et que évidemment nos
concitoyens
avoir une retraite digne nous proposons
avec ces amendements de précisément
réinjecter ces sommes qui aujourd'hui
s'en vont vers ces instruments de
placement financiers avec tous les
risques qui viennent d'être évoqués et
de les réinjecter dans la solidarité
dans le système de répartition en
augmentant un certain nombre de
cotisations notamment sur les plus hauts
revenus puisqu'il s'agit comme je l'ai
précisé du plafond sécurité sociale qui
est à 366 euros mensuels le les
cotisations que nous évoquons ne sont
pas de nature à remettre en cause
considérablement le niveau de vie de nos
concitoyens qui seraient concernés par
ces légères augmentations de cotisations
mais cela permettrait de d'essayer de
rétablir une certaine égalité au sens où
aujourd'hui un cadre à dans notre pays
en moyenne un peu plus de 6 ans
d'espérance de vie par rapport à un
ouvrier
et que donc faire cotiser un petit peu
plus les plus hauts revenus qui sont
souvent les métiers de l'encadrement par
rapport au salaire les plus faibles nous
permettrait de rétablir un peu de
justice je vous remercie merci Madame
moulin le 4274 madame apourse aux poli
monsieur le Président une nouvelle fois
je vais vous faire la démonstration du
caractère purement dogmatique des choix
gouvernementaux concernant l'avenir du
régime de retraite les chiffres sont là
des moyens existent non seulement pour
refuser le recul de l'âge de du départ à
la retraite mais aussi pour revenir à la
retraite à 60 ans à taux plein cette
réforme ni juste ni nécessaire est
imposée par les marchés il n'est pas
compliqué de comprendre que ces marchés
détenteurs en partie du devenir de la
dette de notre pays exerce une forme de
chantage via les constitutions
européennes en exigeant contre leur
bienveillance la privatisation massive
de l'économie y compris l'économie
sociale
reculez l'âge de la retraite c'est faire
le bonheur de la capitalisation en
poussant ce qu'ils peuvent acheter des
années de leur vie à la retraite en
bonne santé auprès des établissements
financiers aujourd'hui le régime est en
équilibre monsieur le ministre vous ne
pouvez pas le nier les scénarios les
plus pessimistes du PER
un déficit de 12 milliards d'euros en
2027 et de 13,5 à l'horizon 2023 rien ne
justifiait la précipitation actuelle à
coup de 47,1 vous avez provoqué la crise
vous avez tendu la société et provoquer
l'affrontement social et politique c'est
amendement parmi les autres fait le
choix d'une augmentation ciblée des
cotisations sociales sachez que leur
augmentation de 0,8 comblerait le
déficit précipité de 12,7 milliards mais
bien d'autres leviers existent pour
financer une grande avancée sociale pas
au service des financiers je vous
remercie merci le 4273
qui le présente Madame linman
oui chers collègues notre amendement est
un moment est un amendement de repli
puisque nous sommes toujours dans le
déplafonnement des cotisations mais nous
avons baissé un tout petit peu le niveau
de ce déplafonnement tant pour les
salariés dont je vous rappelle que seuls
qui gagnent plus de 366 euros serait
concernés et d'autre part pour les
entreprises je voudrais quand même
rappeler que pourquoi ces propositions
c'est que l'enjeu c'est les recettes
l'enjeu c'est la justice dans les
cotisations pour assurer la retraite
plutôt que de d'arriver à allonger la
durée légale auxquelles pour avoir accès
à cette retraite or vous vous tirez
toujours un trait sur tout hypothèse de
nouvelles retraites ne croyez pas que
nos concitoyens qui ne sont évidemment
pas des fanatiques de l'impôt et du
prélèvement ne soit aussi O vous
l'imaginez à cette hypothèse car des
récents sondages ont clairement montré
qu'il préférait nettement une hausse des
cotisations dont je vous rappelle que
dans le cas présent ne touche que à
certains niveaux de salaire plutôt que
ces deux ans de travail supplémentaires
ils envoient les conséquences et la
dureté et il préfère une légère
augmentation des prélèvements mais
indépendamment de ça il y a des zones
grises de de secs de rémunération qui
n'ont pas de prélèvement et plus vous
êtes en situation de ne pas faire
cotiser l'intéressement les primes etc
plus vous vous théorisez le fait que le
salaire qui est quand même le cœur de la
rémunération ne doit pas être augmenté
et vous multipliez les primes enfin
multipliées il y a quand même que 700
000 personnes qui ont touché le la prime
Macron quand on voit la masse des
salariés c'est quand même très loin
merci le
4272 monsieur gay
non non le 4272 le 73 vient d'être
présenté
je vais vous faire plaisir monsieur le
Président je vais défendre le 4272 par
cet amendement nous proposons d'inscrire
à spécifiquement dans l'article
l241-3 du code de la sécurité sociale un
nouveau taux de cotisations sociales
nous proposons que celui-ci soit fixé
premièrement à 0,40 % pour les salariés
et 1,90 pour les employeurs sur la part
des revenus inférieurs au plafond
mentionné au présent arctique et
deuxièmement à 2,42% pour les salariés
et à 4,72 pour les employeurs sur la
part des revenus strictement supérieurs
au même plafond cette proposition
s'inscrit avec d'autres dans notre
volonté de démontrer qu'il existe
d'autres moyens pour assurer pérenniser
le régime de retraite par les partition
que celui de reculer l'âge du départ à
la retraite c'est-à-dire de voler deux
années durant une retraite en bonne
santé si utile à la société plutôt que
d'aller chercher l'argent là où il est
chez les plus riches
je profite de cet instant pour vous
rappeler que l'annulation des
exonérations de cotisations sociales
soit près de 85 milliards d'euros prévus
pour 2023 rapporterait de suite
18,4 milliards pour la branche
vieillesse sans compter les économies
pour le budget de l'État qui est
actuellement compense ces exonérations
augmenter les cotisations sociales
supprimer les exonérations indus
participerez à les forums importants
pour revenir à la retraite à 60 ans et
porter à 2000 euros brut la retraite
minimum réforme qui exigerait 100
milliards d'euros par an l'instauration
d'une cotisation pour les retraites sur
les dividendes nets 50 milliards d'euros
en 2021 à hauteur de 28% comme pour les
salaires rapporterait 14 milliards
d'euros et une hausse de 5% des salaires
dans le privé et 5% du point d'indice
des fonctionnaires rapporterait
respectivement 9 milliards et un
milliard et demi pour la branche
retraite voici quelques pistes que nous
donnons et aux ministres et à la droite
sénatoriale
merci Monsieur Gaëlle 4271 madame Brulin
merci monsieur le Président notre
collègue Marie-Noël Lindeman a eu raison
de rappeler que la plupart de nos
concitoyens qui refusent de voir
l'allongement de la retraite de l'âge de
départ en retraite à 64 ans lorsqu'ils
sont interrogés y compris dans le
contexte de pouvoir d'achat
particulièrement abîmé que nous
connaissons pensent et préféreraient
voir une augmentation de leur
cotisations c'est précisément ce que
nous proposons et encore une fois nous
voulons c'est ce relèvement du niveau de
cotisation minimes sur les contribuables
les plus aisés qui ne n'en
ressentiraient quasiment pas le
contrecoup sur leur vie quotidienne
d'autant qu'ils sont aujourd'hui
à nombreux à investir dans des
instruments financiers de capitalisation
et encore une fois nous proposons de le
réinjecter ces sommes assez colossales
dans le système de solidarité il faut
savoir par exemple que les nouveaux
plans épargne retraite que nous évoquons
depuis plusieurs interventions qui ont
été lancées il y a deux ans représentent
plus de la moitié des cotisations
retraite supplémentaires selon l'adresse
la Direction de la recherche des études
de l'évaluation et des statistiques à
annoncé que cette hausse s'explique
essentiellement par le développement du
PER individuel dont les versements
représentent près des trois quarts des
cotisations sur les dispositifs
individuels 73% pour être précise fin
2020 près fin 2021 pardon près de 20
milliards d'euros de cotisations ont été
collectés dans le cadre du contrat de
retraite supplémentaire un montant en
hausse de 27% en euros courant par
rapport à la fin 2020 la collecte par
les nouveaux per dépend du type de
contrat individuel d'entreprises
collectif ou d'entreprises obligatoires
et ils ont enregistré respectivement 8
milliards 2,2 milliards et 970 millions
d'euros de cotisations voilà qui
pourrait venir abonder
utilement le régime par répartition je
vous remercie
le
4270 monsieur Bocquet monsieur le
Président mon intervention vaudra à
présentation des deux amendements qui
viennent de 42 70 et le 42 69 comme quoi
il ne faut jamais désespérer du groupe
communiste
depuis les semaines le gouvernement
argue que la réforme demeure absolument
indispensable incontournable avec une
approche budgétaire et financière
démographique nous dit-on le système de
retraite serait déficitaire d'environ 18
milliards d'euros par an et nous ne
serions pas à l'équilibre avant le
milieu des années 2030
pourtant nous souhaitons rappeler ici
que dès 2020 le Conseil d'orientation
des retraites qui a servi de boussole à
beaucoup d'entre nous nuancer ce constat
je cite le système de retraite n'est pas
menacé et le déficit serait de l'ordre
de 0,3% du PIB maximum à l'horizon 2025
c'est un niveau qui n'a rien d'alarmant
vous en conviendrez les dernières études
du corps vont plus loin les dépenses de
retraite ont été revues à la baisse les
pensions représentaient 14% du PIB avant
la crise les études indiquent qu'elles
sont aujourd'hui autour de 13,7%. la
nuance de donc -03% est importante
d'autant que les trajectoires indiquent
que la part des retraites dans le PIB
continuera de baisser dans les années à
venir dans ces conditions nous propos
une solution pour remédier aux déficit
temporaire par la création d'une
contribution additionnelle des plafonnée
sur l'ensemble des revenus d'activités
dont le taux serait de 1,4% pour les
salariés et de 3,4% pour les employeurs
cette solution ne pénaliserait ni les
bases salaires ni les travailleurs en
deçà d'un revenu mensuel de 366 euros ni
les personnes assujetties je vous
remercie merci le 4346
4346 qui le présente
il est défendu il est défendu le 434
monsieur Bocquet
oui merci monsieur le Président la
question du niveau de cotisation
patronale pour financer l'assurance
vieillesse est un véritable sujet chacun
en conviendra nous amendements vont dans
le sens une augmentation des cotisations
patronales car du côté des salariés des
efforts ont été faits depuis 30 ans et
ont entraîné de l'ours sacrifice pour
nous ce ne sont des reculs sociaux qui
sont bien sûr fortement préjudiciables à
nos compatriotes mais je rappelle que
depuis 1993 le montant des pensions de
retraite n'est plus calculée en fonction
des dix meilleures années mais sur les
25 meilleures années depuis cette
année-là le nombre de trimestres de
cotisations pour une pension complète et
passer de 37 années et demi soit 150
trimestres à 40 années soit 160
trimestres depuis 1993 les pensions des
retraités ne sont plus indexées sur les
salaires brut mais sur les prix
entraînant un ralentissement de leur
revalorisation et par conséquent une
diminution de leur pouvoir d'achat
depuis 93 les régimes spéciaux ont été
alignés sur les conditions du régime
général au détriment de la prise en
compte de la pénibilité des métiers il
en fut question hier dans cette
hémicycle pour ces raisons nous
considérons que le patronat doit
accepter de payer davantage chez
salariés en remontant le niveau de
cotisation afin d'augmenter le salaire
socialisé qui est le fondement même de
notre système de sécurité sociale merci
et enfin pour cette discussion commune
le 4345
il est défendu
[Musique]
merci le ministre cher collègue tous ces
amendements proposent en réalité
d'augmenter les cotisations surtout sur
les cotisations patronales ou alors de
changer le taux pour les salaires les
plus hauts donc en réalité ça revient à
dire qu'il faut charger charger les les
charges de l'entreprise
charger les charges de l'entreprise et
de toutes les entreprises parce que
lorsque l'on lit vos amendements il n'y
a pas pour le secteur privé un taux
particulier le secteur public etc pour
le milieu associatif aussi on pourrait
se dire c'est tous les secteurs donc
vous chargez l'entreprise ça veut dire
aussi que vous chargez les coûts de
production ça veut dire que encore une
fois la compétitivité de la France est
en mis en jeu c'est aussi
sans doute avoir des répercussions sur
l'emploi or nous cherchons à avoir le
plein emploi mais pas supprimer des
emplois en tout cas pas à ralentir le
niveau d'emploi qu'il y a dans notre
pays donc attention c'est la première
attention que je voulais dire dans notre
pays les cotisations sont déjà rendues à
un très haut niveau j'ai eu l'occasion
de le dire il suffit de regarder la
déclaration sociale nominative de
Jacques entreprises et lorsqu'on regarde
ces déclarations vous verrez le niveau
de cotisation
auquel on est rendu et c'est vraiment
très très important et est-ce que ce
serait le bon moment alors que les
entreprises mais comme les Français ont
des difficultés aujourd'hui par rapport
au coût de l'énergie par rapport aux
enjeux aussi qu'ils sont à même de
relever par rapport à la décarbonation
par exemple ils ont beaucoup d'enjeux
ils ont des efforts à faire sur on l'a
dit ce matin les carrières hachées sur
le temps partiel sur le niveau de femme
qui sont intégrés dans l'ensemble des
salariés ils ont des progrès à faire par
rapport au Seigneur et vous leur
rajoutez des charges alors la Commission
a décidé que ce serait un avis
défavorable
de la commission monsieur le ministre
pour le gouvernement
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs on est ici au
coeur du débat sur le financement de
notre système de retraite et moi s'il y
a un point dont je me satisfais avec ces
amendements c'est qu'à travers ses
amendements vous reconnaissez qu'il y a
un problème de financement de notre
système de retraite mais ça a pu faire
débat y compris médiatiquement ces
derniers mois ou parfois on a entendu
certains responsables politiques en tout
cas dans des médias remettre en cause le
fait qu'il y aurait un problème de
financement de notre système de retraite
qui serait déséquilibré puisque vous
proposez d'augmenter des cotisations pas
vous n'en mettra bien si vous
reconnaissez non mais si vous proposez
des augmentations de cotisation c'est
bien que vous reconnaissez qu'il y a un
problème de financement pour notre
système et que si on ne fait rien dans
quelques années on aura un gros problème
pour payer les pensions des retraités si
on ne prend pas les bonnes décisions à
partir de là il y a plusieurs
possibilités et effectivement votre
ligne elle mérite de la cohérence ou
proposer d'augmenter la pression fiscale
sociale les impôts les cotisations en
l'occurrence ici des
cotisations
cotisations sur l'entreprise ou
cotisation sur le salarié
il y a un certain nombre d'amendements
on voit que c'est une longue discussion
commune donc c'est des taux qui sont
différents à chaque fois des assiettes
qui sont différents à chaque fois mais
globalement vous proposer soit
d'augmenter les cotisations pour
l'employeur soit pour le salarié et
contrairement à ce que j'ai pu entendre
pas uniquement pour les salariés qui
auraient un salaire supérieur à 3700
j'ai entendu ça non non non parfois dans
certains exposés des motifs il y a écrit
c'est que pour les salariés qui sont à
plus de 3600 euros mais quand vous lisez
l'amendement et je peux vous dire que
mes services les ont bien analysés
notamment le 4284 c'est une augmentation
de cotisations salariale qui
s'appliquerait à tous les salariés tous
les salariés de la manière dont les
amendements sont rédigés ça veut dire
qu'un salarié au Smic avec votre
amendement ils perdrait 410 euros de
salaire sur l'année un salarié au Smic
alors j'ai entendu certains dire ces
quelques dizaines d'euros par mois c'est
pas grand chose enfin je me souviens
qu'au moment des 5 euros d'APL on nous
expliquait que 5 euros c'était énorme
donc là en l'occurrence là en
l'occurrence vous retirez plusieurs
dizaines voire une trentaine d'euros à
des salariés dans un moment d'inflation
on sait que certains nombre de
françaises sont en difficulté donc je
suis pas évidemment en accord ensuite il
y a d'autres amendements effectivement
où c'est des augmentations de cotisation
salariale qui démarre à 2900 euros de
salaire net de 1900 euros de salaire net
c'est ça veut dire que vous touchez un
quart des salariés alors effectivement
c'est ceux qui gagnent plus de 2900
euros moi simplement j'arrête sur un
point vous avez aujourd'hui 10% des
Français qui payent 70% de l'impôt sur
le revenu
vous avez des Français qui travaillent
qui travaillent dur qui peuvent être
dans ce niveau de salaire qui voit
beaucoup d'argent public qui est investi
dépensé pour accompagner des Français
qui ne travaillent pas moi j'arrête
aussi sur les classe moyennes françaises
qui aujourd'hui ont le sentiment qu'on
leur demande toujours à elle les efforts
pour financer des mesures qui ne les
concernent jamais donc moi je suis en
désaccord avec cette ligne là mais c'est
un c'est un beau débat c'est un beau
débat je pense que ces amendements
entraîneraient soit une destruction
d'emplois soit une destruction de
pouvoir d'achat et dans les deux cas j'y
suis défavorable maintenant pour
répondre à deux interventions précises
des spécifiques monsieur gay vous m'avez
interrogé sur les exonérations de
cotisations
l'état compense aujourd'hui 70 milliards
d'euros d'exonération de cotisation
sociale qui ont eu lieu sous tous les
gouvernements je citais tout à l'heure
l'exemple sur le gouvernement de
François Hollande avec 25 milliards
d'exonérations de cotisations sociales
je pourrais citer un gouvernement auquel
vous participiez pas vous monsieur gay
mais en tout cas les communistes Lionel
Jospin il a doublé l'exonération non
mais il était pas au gouvernement madame
assassin il était il était encore plus
jeune comme moi mais les communistes
participaient à l'époque à la gauche
plurielle Lionel Jospin son gouvernement
a doublé le montant des exonérations de
cotisations sociales elles sont passées
de 10 à 20 milliards sous cette
législatures et l'Insee c'était en
parallèle des 35 heures c'était en
parallèle 35 heures effectivement
l'Insee l'Insee a estimé à 300 000
emplois créé via ses exonérations
sociales qui ont augmenté donc il y a
ces 70 milliards de compensations de
l'État à la sécurité sociale et je vous
confirme qu'il n'est pas du tout prévu
de revenir sur ces cette compensation
par l'État c'était votre question
deuxième point sur lequel je voulais
revenir et j'en finirai là monsieur le
Président c'est madame lilleman vous
avez parlé de la prime Macron et vous
avez indiqué que 700000 salariés
seulement avait perçu la prime Macron je
viens de publier les chiffres 2022 c'est
5 millions 500000 salariés qui ont
bénéficié de la prime Macron 5 millions
500000 et pas des salariés dans des
grandes entreprises ou des
multinationales 2 millions de salariés
qui ont reçu la prime sont dans des
entreprises de moins de 50 salariés et
là où le montant de la prime Macron est
le plus élevé c'est dans les TPE puisque
c'est 1000 euros de prix Macron en
moyenne donc on n'est pas du tout dans
les chiffres que vous avez donné au
contraire c'est un très bel outil de
partage de la valeur dans l'entreprise
évidemment qu'on soutient avis
défavorable sur tous ces amendements
donc un double avis des favorable alors
j'ai avant que tout passion au vote j'ai
un certain nombre de demandes de
d'explications de vote madame linman
première réaction celle liées aux
déclarations de notre rapporteur
madame la rapporteur la thèse selon
laquelle en augmentant les cotisations
raisonnablement nos propositions sont
pas énormes des cotisations
patronales de retraite onirait à la
compétitivité des entreprises françaises
permettez-moi de vous dire que ça fait
partie des des ronrons qu'on répète sans
preuve la preuve si je puis dire inverse
et ben justement
150 milliards dans le de baisse de
cotisation et le et le déficit
commercial se creuse pourquoi parce que
la stratégie il y a plus il y a plus de
stratégie industrielles parce qu'on a
laissé faire le dumping social parce
qu'on a laissé augmenter le prix de
l'énergie à cause du marché européen
tous les éléments de compétitivité
historique de la France vous les avez
laissés affaiblir par des choix
européens et il vous reste plus qu'une
seule chose c'est d'essayer de baisser
le entre guillemets ou du travail et ça
ne marche pas ça ne marche pas il faut
des politiques industrielles il faut
mais c'est pas selon moi la balance
commerciale on est tous d'accord pour
qu'on s'était qu'elle est abyssale bon
donc la réalité c'est que ce n'est pas
le mot de notre la parole si des
collègues des républicains veulent
s'inscrire c'est tout à fait possible
mais oui surtout répondez-moi chers
collègues ne manquez pas cet
argumentation si nécessaire à notre
débat
de deuxième sujet oui notre nous
demandons une augmentation de l'assiette
de l'assiette des cotisants pas du
niveau massif des cotisants alors
évidemment parfois on élargissant
l'assiette on tombe sur un nombre de
cotisation mais mon collègue Fabien gay
ou d'autres vous expliqueront pourquoi
merci Madame Poncet Monge
merci monsieur le Président alors
préalablement quand même je voudrais
adresser à Monsieur Attal une supplique
qu'il sait c'est provocations
et il devrait d'ailleurs
vous voulez qu'on aille plus vite si
vous provoquez on va aller plus
lentement et notamment je me rappelle
que le la décision de l'intersyndical
mais je vois que la terre syndicale vous
l'a pas envoyé donc je vais lui demander
de l'envoyer se terminait par le souhait
qu'à partir de demain on mette la France
à l'arrêt mettre la France à la race ce
n'est pas la France à genoux c'est la
France à genoux vous vous en occupez
donc je voudrais donc ah oui d'ailleurs
cette
guidance sur
l'amendement 42 83 modifié
et donc je voudrais revenir sur le
problème justement des cotisations
j'ai vu monsieur Attal que vous êtes
attentif au sondage alors je vais vous
en donner un
66%. c'est-à-dire de tiers des 18 à 24
ans jeune actif sont favorables à
l'augmentation de les cotisations plutôt
enfin comme levier plutôt que le levier
que vous activez vous l'allongement de
l'âge d'ouverture des droits à la
retraite et cette tranche d'âge qui est
favorable à deux tiers à l'augmentation
des cotisations ce n'est pas une tranche
d'âge favorisée sur le plan du pouvoir
d'achat donc ça se ferait bien que vous
ne parliez pas en au nom des salariés
quant à ce pouvoir d'achat et je termine
aussi sur le fait que pour ce qui est de
la compétitivité alors là bon c'est
peut-être un peu plus votre sujet nous
n'avons pas le même diagnostic ce n'est
pas le coup du travail qui pèse sur la
compétitivité c'est le coût du capital
quand les dividendes oui quand les
dividendes font 10% du PIB quand les
camps pour avoir des profits on a une
stratégie dénitaire de d'investissement
oui c'est le coup du capital qui plombe
la compétitivité merci Madame pour ces
mots je la parole à Monsieur à Madame
briquet pardon madame briquet
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues alors que
les inégalités se creusent la réforme
des retraites proposées par le
gouvernement va contribuer à renforcer
ces inégalités le prétexte financier mis
en avant par le gouvernement n'est pas
crédible il existe en effet de
nombreuses sources de financement qui
permettraient de ne pas pénaliser à
nouveau les travailleurs et les
travailleuses tout en renforçant une
solidarité largement mise à mal depuis
plusieurs années mais votre retraite
monsieur le ministre n'est pas une
réforme de notre système de retraite
c'est une mesure d'économie que vous
avez choisie délibérément un arbitrage
économique Bruno Le Maire ne s'ennuie
jamais caché d'ailleurs c'est le moyen
choisi pour envoyer un signe à Bruxelles
et afficher ainsi une réduction globale
du déficit que ce gouvernement lui-même
aggravé
mais aussi et surtout pour suivre sa
politique d'allègement fiscal pour les
plus aisés et le désarmement fiscal de
notre pays belle manière de dire aux
Français les plus modestes payer et
payer toujours contentez-vous du peu de
service public qui résiste encore et
cerise sur le gâteau travailler et
cotiser deux ans de plus
merci Madame briquet la parole à
Monsieur Chaumier
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre moi j'ai aucune leçon à
recevoir en terme d'équilibre des
comptes publics d'un gouvernement qui a
à ce point détérioré ces comptes qui est
à ce point-là le déficit de la balance
commerciale au zénith et qui maintenant
plonge le budget de chaque Français dans
une grande difficulté nous avons
toujours dit que effectivement il
fallait regarder comment mieux
équilibrer le régime des retraites mais
le problème c'est là où c'est le cœur du
problème cette discussion c'est que
toutes les pistes relatives au
cotisations vous les écartez donc
évidemment vous utilisez quel levier le
plus injuste le report de l'âge légal de
deux ans celui qui pénalise le plus les
plus modestes et les travailleurs en
situation les plus les plus pénibles
madame la rapporteur nous dit il faut
pas tenter à la compétitivité économique
des entreprises oui mais il y a des
exonérations qui n'ont aucun impact sur
l'emploi le Conseil d'analyse économique
l'a dit et seule là non plus quand on
propose de les supprimer vous ne voulez
pas pourquoi
les quatre entreprises il y a 4
entreprises françaises qui elles seules
l'année dernière on fait 64 milliards de
bénéfices
64 milliards pour quatre entreprises
nous avons proposé aussi de regarder
comment on pouvait les mettre à
contribution sans je vous rassure les
plonger dans un déficit abyssal et bien
vous refusez aussi donc c'est une ligne
idéologique que vous avez qui est
respectable mais vous dites on ne
touchera pas au cotisations on ne
touchera pas à ce que les entreprises
payent donc évidemment à partir de ce
moment là et équilibrer les comptes bah
vous utilisez des leviers qui ne pèsent
que sur les salariés et que sur les
salariés les plus modestes c'est un
juste et nous on soutiendra ses
amendements
merci Monsieur chanterelle
merci monsieur le Président je vois que
vous êtes tenté de réagir de répondre et
c'est normal parce qu'il y a une vraie
confrontation entre nous sur ce sujet là
sur la vision que vous avez d'ailleurs
madame la rapporteur vous parlez en
permanence de charge et c'est un
supportable ce ne sont pas des charges
et ça a été très même le ministre ne dit
pas Charles d'ailleurs Eddy cotisation
j'ai relevé mais c'est des cotisations
effectivement qui participent à notre
système de protection sociale pour
protéger les gens contre les accidents
de la vie c'est du salaire différé ce ne
sont pas des charges donc déjà employer
les bons mots parler de parler de
cotisations d'ailleurs c'est pas vous
pouvez intervenir vous inquiétez pas
monsieur monsieur le ministre d'ailleurs
et ça a été très bien rappelé par mon
collègue jaumier vous utilisez
effectivement la variable la plus
injuste celle du relèvement de l'âge
légal de départ de retraite à 64 ans et
par contre on vous avait au moins une
cohérence
que vous suivez avec abnégation depuis 6
ans c'est vous ne souhaitez pas
effectivement que les plus fortunés que
les gens qui possèdent le plus ne
participent pas la solidarité nationale
ça vous avez cette cohérence là c'est
pour ça que nous soutiendrons bien
évidemment c'est amendement parce que la
solidarité c'est de la faire peser à
ceux qui ont de plus mais depuis 6 ans
vous ne faites que diminuer les
cotisations vous ne faites que diminuer
les impôts des plus fortunés mais il y a
de quoi enragé il y a de quoi mettre en
colère les Français les Françaises et
vous le diront massivement à nouveau
dans la rue demain pour que vous
retiriez cette réforme profondément
injuste et brutale vis-à-vis des plus
démunis de ce pays
[Applaudissements]
madame madame Bruno
merci monsieur le président
nous sommes en train de débattre de
quelque chose qui me semble extrêmement
sérieux et qu'il faudrait qu'on le fasse
de manière approfondie on est dans un
pays qui refuse absolument massivement
de travailler deux ans de plus et qui va
le redire avec force et encore plus
massivement demain à partir de là ou
bien vous vous entêtez à aller dans
cette voie et je ne sais pas où ça nous
conduira parce que tout a montré que
vous avez beau défendre argumenter ce
projet de loi ça met toujours plus de
monde dans la rue plus de monde en
colère nous nous ouvrons le débat sur
d'autres possibilités de financer la
retraite parce que monsieur le ministre
je trouve je vous trouve d'une mauvaise
foi caractérisée
nous n'avons jamais dit qu'il n'y avait
pas de problème de financement nous
n'avons fait que redire ce que dit le
corps lui-même c'est qu'il n'y a pas de
dérapage incontrôlé qui nous met en
péril dans ces toutes prochaines années
mais par contre bien sûr qui a des
sources de financement à trouver parce
que réforme après réforme
c'est ce sont c'est le niveau de pension
de nos concitoyens qui a diminué qui
risquent de diminuer encore
considérablement donc si nous voulons
assurer à chacun une retraite digne oui
il va falloir chercher des sources de
financement nous disons aussi que il
faut tenter de retourner vers la
retraite à 60 ans parce que quand on
voit le taux d'emploi actuel entre 60 et
62 ans on voit bien qu'il y a un sujet
qui en a qui ne peuvent plus bosser dans
ces âges-là et bien donc ça va
nécessiter d'aller chercher des sources
de financement vous à vos propositions
diverses que nous faisons notamment sur
la cotisation vous ne répondez de
manière obsessionnelle que par
exonération de cotisation et recule de
l'âge nous demandons à ouvrir ce débat
nous le devons aux Français je crois
qu'il nous attendent là-dessus et que ce
débat de société aurait un très grand
intérêt pour chacun merci Madame Bruno
la parole est à Monsieur broyé
merci monsieur le Président non non vous
n'aurez pas d'indice merci monsieur le
ministre vous évoquez le déséquilibre
nous n'augions pas qu'il y a un problème
de recettes et même nous faisons
beaucoup de propositions mais vous
refusez avec un peu d'entêtement il faut
le dire d'envisager cet aspect de
l'équation vous cheminez toujours dans
la même direction finalement pour vous
les cotisations ça n'est pas bien mais
il y a d'ailleurs d'autres possibilités
par exemple le fond de réserve des
retraites pourrait bien être alimentée
par une partie des 56,9 milliards de
dividendes versés l'année dernière
record d'Europe quand même détenu par
notre pays alors face à cette situation
la nécessité de trouver des recettes
mais coller communiste ont dans un souci
je dois dire très détaillé de rechercher
le compromis ont été chercher plusieurs
points d'équilibre possible et
acceptable par notre hémicycle
monsieur le ministre vous refusez donc
cette solution proposée par nos
collègues mais vous vous en choisissez
une qui est de prendre deux ans de la
vie de nos concitoyens vous êtes jeune
vous ne voyez sans doute pas la valeur
du temps qu'il reste à vivre pour les
gens plus âgés mais permettait à un
jeune sénateur comme vous l'avez
souligné qui voit cependant la ligne
d'arrivée plus proche sans doute que la
vôtre de vous dire qu'il faut que les
gens aient du temps pour vivre pour
aimer pour s'occuper de leurs enfants de
leurs petits-enfants et prendre deux ans
c'est l'injustice la plus grande que
nous puissions faire et ces millions de
personnes qui demain seront dans la rue
vous le diront vous le répéteront ils
veulent vivre et notre pays on a besoin
dans la vie associative dans l'aide aux
enfants dans l'aide aux parents
dépendants et puis simplement pour leur
permettre de vivre parce qu'on a aussi
le droit de vivre et de ne rien faire
merci
Monsieur Assouline
oui j'ai entendu deux arguments de du
ministre le premier c'est celui là c'est
quand même incroyable que vous êtes en
train de nous dire en gros
que prendre deux ans de la vie des gens
c'est quelque chose oui prendre deux ans
de la vie prendre
c'est prendre deux ans de la vie
autrement qu'au travail de ceux qui ont
trimé toute leur vie en attendant aussi
ce moment où ils vont pouvoir faire
autre chose
et vous nous le mettez en balance comme
si c'est un coup c'est une régression et
vous nous donnez l'exemple de Lionel
Jospin enfin le problème c'est que
Lionel Jospin quand il fait des
exonérations c'est pour soulager
l'économie parce que il crée un progrès
social historique pour les travailleurs
qui sont les 35 heures là vous dites que
il ne faut pas de comme si c'était
inconnu le fait que vous proposez au
cœur de votre effort une régression
sociale historique encore avec deux ans
de recul de l'âge légal de la retraite
et puis
il y a
la situation c'est à dire le corps nous
dit qu'il y a une maîtrise il ne dit pas
effectivement qu'il n'y aura pas de
problème avec la démographie actuelle de
financement des retraites à terme mais
il dit qu'aujourd'hui c'est maîtrisé et
on entend aujourd'hui monsieur Véran
venir nous dire que ce qu'il voulait
dire avant c'est que le gouvernement a
d'autres urgences que la question de la
réforme des retraites alors pourquoi au
moment où il y a l'inflation où les gens
n'arrivent plus à vivre et pas seulement
ce qui était déjà pauvre mais les
classes moyennes qui basculent pourquoi
dans ce moment où les salaires restent
bas et face à l'inflation régresse le
pouvoir d'achat pourquoi dans ce moment
cette réforme précipitée pour encore
plus attaquer au monde pour que insuline
merci Madame Cohen
lors de sa campagne électorale le
président de la République avait affirmé
l'ambition nous faire travailler plus
longtemps pour préserver l'équilibre des
comptes publics au détriment d'une
certaine idée de notre protection
sociale le débat parlementaire doit
évidemment s'intéresser au financement
du système tout en répondant à l'urgence
du moment alors que les inquiétudes
suscitées par le projet de loi sont
fortes vous demandez un effort aux
françaises et aux français alors que
nous vivons une crise aiguë en matière
d'accès aux soins mais qu'est-ce que
vous donnez au retour rien du tout la
rupture d'égalité est permanente et
l'injustice vertigineuse le prix de du
lit de naissance a de nouveau atteint
près de 2 euros les étudiants sont de
plus en plus nombreux à faire la queue
aux banques alimentaires et malgré la
hausse du coût de la vie vous demandez
aux Français de sacrifier deux années de
plus et mes collègues l'ont très bien
dit pendant ce temps les écarts de
salaires entre les mieux payés et les
moins bien payés en France progresse la
rémunération moyenne annuelle des
dirigeants du CAC 40 est de 239 soit
environ 4,6 millions d'euros en 2021
elle culmine même à 1070 SMIC pour
Bernard Charles le directeur général de
Dassault Systèmes c'est quand même pas
mal ces écarts dépassent la raison et
les inégalités sont tellement fortes en
bas de l'échelle de l'entreprise avec
celle des dirigeants qu'il est
indispensable d'agir des deux bouts en
augmentant le SMIC bien évidemment et
les salaires les plus bas et en mettant
à contribution plus fortement les hauts
salaires par une surcotisation pour
rétablir la justice et ce que nous vous
demandons chaque année les communistes
vous demandent au moment de l'examen de
la sécurité du budget de la Sécurité
sociale de faire entrer des recettes
parce que les caisses qui sont asséchés
asséchés de la sécurité sociale des
retraites c'est vous qui les asséchez il
faut c'est pas un une des dépenses
supplémentaires c'est des recettes en
moins par les exonérations alors
entendez-nous une bonne fois pour toute
toute façon demain dans la rue des
millions de gens vont encore crier vont
mettre le pays à l'arrêt et nous serons
avec eux parce que c'est ce qu'il faut
faire pour vous entendiez enfin merci
Madame Cohen la parole est maintenant à
Madame A poursaut poli
madame Cohen elle prend le haut moi je
prends le bas bon monsieur le Président
merci finalement faut bien se détendre
de temps en temps finalement tout au
long de ce débat une véritable une
vérité émerge pour financer les
retraites ce qu'il faut augmenter ce
sont les salaires et pas l'âge de départ
monsieur le ministre inlassablement nous
dénonçons cette manipulation qui
consiste à affirmer que notre système de
retraite serait en danger oui c'est vrai
il peut l'être mais du fait de vos choix
du fait des choix libéraux tâche rien
que vous voulez imposer à notre pays en
livrant au secteur privé la gestion de
nos fins de vie mais objectivement il
n'est pas en danger car des solutions
existent des moyens de financement
existent vous faites peur à notre peuple
peur aux salariés vous l'inquiétez pour
jeter ce qui auront demain les moyens
dans les bras de la capitalisation oui
des solutions existent nous le cessons
de vous le répéter en mettant à
contribution les dividendes en assumant
l'égalité salariale homme-femme pourquoi
alors refusez-vous de faire participer
le capital au redressement de la
protection sociale vous faites un choix
politique qui n'est pas celui de
l'intérêt général
oui nous sommes et nous le voyons bien
dans ce débat projet contre projet
pourquoi ne débattez-vous pas de ce
chiffre 5% d'augmentation des salaires
dans le privé ces 9 milliards de
cotisations supplémentaires pour la
branche retraite quelle mesure le
gouvernement prend-il pour augmenter les
salaires qui finalement sont le fruit de
ce débat également parce que petit
salaire petite retraite nous le savons
tous pourquoi ne bougez-vous pas sur le
SMIC nous poursuivrons le débat jusqu'à
ce que vous apportiez des réponses à ces
questions qui nous semblent essentielles
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues je trouve qu'on est dans un
affrontement gauche-droite
et oui parce que monsieur le ministre a
raison soit on prend deux années de vie
et les deux plus belles années à la
retraite à des millions de travailleurs
et travailleurs soit on trouve des
nouvelles pistes de financement c'est ça
la réalité et donc nous on vous propose
dans cette série là d'élargir la sienne
pour les hauts revenus ce supérieur à
3667 euros on aura d'autres pistes de
financement on l'a dit et surtout les
bancs si on fait enfin l'égalité
salariale dans ce pays c'est de suite 6
milliards de cotisations sociales si on
gagne la bataille de l'emploi un million
de travailleurs et travailleuses de plus
en activité c'est de suite 10 milliards
ou si on fait cotiser les revenus du
capital au même titre que ceux du
travail alors là je vous dis pas c'est
26 milliards d'euros donc vous voyez
nous on est sur des nouvelles pistes de
financement on vous offre une palette
décidant étrangers entre nous la
majorité du peuple français va vous le
redire demain avec grande force personne
ne veut travailler deux ans de plus
parce que s'il travaille et source
d'épanouissement et de liens social pour
beaucoup de travailleurs et
travailleuses les utiles essentiels de
ce pays c'est aussi source de souffrance
psychiques et physique et donc non on ne
veut pas voler les deux plus belles
années et donc nous pensons qu'il faut
avoir un vrai débat allez arrêter
l'obstruction au silencieuse
débattez avec nous sur quoi vous êtes
d'accord vous voulez pas élargir
l'assiette des hauts revenus très bien
dites nous il y a 10 milliards à trouver
dans une perspective lointaine dans le
20 ou 30 ans donc on a le temps de
débattre
cherchons les chiffres ensemble allons-y
je suis sûr que vous avez aussi des
belles propositions on est prêt à vous
entendre et à se mettre d'accord sur un
compromis
75% des gens ne veulent pas et ils
soutiennent la grève reconductible à
partir de demain on devrait quand même
entendre ça tous ensemble je vous
remercie
madame madame meunier
oui merci monsieur le Président il n'y a
pas de hasard et pourquoi est-ce que ce
projet de loi est si impopulaire
pourquoi est-ce que si Français sur 10
sont opposés à cette réforme c'est parce
que ça touche exclusivement les ménages
et les ménages les plus modestes oui il
y a un autre une autre possibilité de
financement des économistes le disent
Michael Zemmour par exemple donne
d'autres pistes et si nous sommes
nombreux ici à défendre les propositions
que nos collègues du groupe CRCE
défendent ici c'est que il est possible
d'avoir un autre financement que de
ponctionner les ménages les plus
modestes et donc devant ce caractère
injuste ses amendements poursuivent le
même objectif rétablir de la justice
sociale sur ce qui n'en est pas
aujourd'hui
merci encore une prise de parole madame
plus Karman ensuite je donnerai la
parole aux rapporteur Savary madame ku
Karman
un débat que nous n'avons pas peut-être
parce que nous ont pas l'aborder mais
qui est finalement est-ce que oui ou non
dans notre pays la retraite à une
utilité sociale
est-ce que oui ou non ce que à la langue
française d'ailleurs à qualifier de
troisième âge puis de quatrième âge
est-ce que c'est temps là de la vie
correspondent un besoin dont chacune et
chacun individuellement doit-on en
ressentir et en approuvé les
satisfactions et est-ce que
collectivement nous avons besoin de ces
femmes de ces hommes que tout un chacun
et je ne ferai l'offense à personne ici
mais que tout à chacun nous rencontrons
au quotidien
vous et nous les connaissons toutes et
tous vous savez
ces milliers d'élus locaux
qui aujourd'hui parce qu'il bénéficie
d'un système de retraite qui leur
permettent de partir à l'âge de la
retraite en bonne santé vous les
connaissez vous les connaissez toutes et
tous ces femmes ces hommes que nous
rencontrons plus régulièrement les
vendredis soirs les samedis après-midi
les dimanches matin ces femmes et ses
hommes qui animent l'ensemble de notre
de nos associations et que même si à la
fin de chaque assemblée générale nous
faisons le constat qu'il faudrait
renouveler nous nous sommes satisfaits
qu'il y a encore ces jeunes retraités
ces retraités dynamiques qui font vivre
ce fameux vivre ensemble que nous
appelons toutes et tous de nos vœux mais
qui les incarne au quotidien vous
connaissez toutes et tous ces femmes et
ces hommes qui devant les sorties
d'écoles sont là pour soulager
accompagner alors oui nous le disons
nous voterons ces différents amendements
Monsieur Merci monsieur le rapporteur
Sabari
oui mais chaque sénateur a le droit de
prendre la parole ainsi juge pas utile
mes collègues
si il juge pas utile mes collègues de
prendre la parole c'est que peut-être
quelque part faut se poser des questions
et que l'effet répétitif d'amendement
similaire modifiant simplement un petit
pourcentage un petit pourcentage de
cotisations
supplémentaires il y a des violences
déviance du débat parlementaire vous
n’expliquez pas votre amendement vous
profitez de la tribune pour faire des
effets tribunes parce que vous savez
qu'on vous regarde et effectivement les
gens nous regardent
il faut leur dire la vérité aux gens
ils prennent pas deux ans à cause de la
réforme
ils prennent selon toujours le mécanisme
que vous connaissez bien des délais
supplémentaires liés effectivement faut
le reconnaître et nous assumons nos
responsabilités un décalage d'âge que
l'on préconise est lié à l'augmentation
de la durée 43 ans qui a fait
l'augmentation de la durée c'est pas 43
ans plus deux ans les gens ont déjà pris
la plupart du temps ils ont pris le
délai supplémentaire
assumez-le parce que c'était facile
excusez-moi c'était facile
merci oui oui
1000 excuses milles excuses
mais
faut assumer tu le rapporteur
de prendre des réformes qui concernent
les suivantes et les réformes tounes
elle commence seulement à s'appliquer et
elle va faire ses effets-là mais
dites-le dans les manifestations si vous
travaillez plus longtemps c'est à cause
de nous quand même et pas forcément à
cause d'eux
donc si vous voulez si vous voulez jouer
sur ce terrain là nous sommes preneurs
mais faut dire l'ensemble des
thématiques les effets positifs et les
effets négatifs alors volontiers vous
voyez à travers le corps une
justification le Conseil d'orientation
des retraites il y a des gens qui nous
écoutent vous voyez des significations
simplement vous oubliez de dire que tous
les scénarios même les plus optimistes
conduisent à une dégradation des comptes
de retraite avec une retraite plus
faible des retraités baisse du pouvoir
relativement au salaire moyen baisse du
pouvoir des retraités
85% à l'horizon 2030 2040 contre 103%
dites-le à vos amis que vous êtes
favorables à une baisse de leur niveau
de vie aux retraités ce sera sans dire
la vérité
et bien face à cela
face à cela face à cela nous sommes
responsables et nous prenons les
décisions qu'il faut parce que nous ne
voulons pas nous que nos enfants à
travailler jusque 65 ans nous ne voulons
pas nous que nos enfants et à travailler
plus de 43 ans 45 46 ans parce que c'est
ça l'équivalent d'une absence de prise
de responsabilité les suivants vont
hériter une dégradation de notre système
et il se la réforme sera encore plus
brutale plus en retard d'apprendre les
décisions plus la réforme est brutale
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
sommes attentifs et je vous invite mes
chers collègues vous qui êtes sensibles
à la prise en compte des mers de famille
d'attendre les articles qui vont
effectivement faire que nous prenons des
mesures tout à fait significatives pour
les maires de famille car nous aussi
nous en parlons pas nous faisons des
propositions
merci merci monsieur le rapporteur
madame Lubin une réaction de Madame
Lubin
alors puisqu'on commence à se parler
puisqu'on commence à se parler
franchement
ah vous étiez impatient alors on va
revenir en arrière on va revenir en
arrière qui sait qui a permis aux
ouvriers de ce pays qui jusqu'en 1981
commençait à travailler à 14 ans qui
finissait à 65 mais ouais c'est pas si
vieux que ça qui finissait à 65 et qui
mourait avant d'avoir tout juste après
avoir profité de quelques mois de
carrière qui c'est qui est revenu en
arrière immédiatement qui sait qu'un 93
à placer le calcul sur les 25 meilleures
années pour faire baisser le niveau des
retraites qui c'est qui en 2010 s'est
passé de 2003 ou 2010 je sais plus qui
est passé et passé de 60 à 62 ans et
malgré tout et malgré tout il a fallu
faire encore des réformes la preuve que
celle que vous aviez faite elles étaient
mauvaises pour les salariés et mauvaise
pour le système pour le régime de
retraite et pour son équilibre c'est ça
la réalité et la réforme Touraine j'ai
eu l'occasion de le dire hier oui elle a
mis à 43 exactement
mais elle a continué à permettre à des
gens qui commençaient à travailler avant
20 ans de partir à 62 et c'est à ça que
vous allez toucher aujourd'hui je vous
ai écouté jusqu'au bout chers collègues
et c'est à ça que vous allez toucher
aujourd'hui alors s'il vous plaît s'il
vous plaît moi ce que je sais quand je
regarde 40 ans en arrière 40 ans c'est
quand j'ai commencé à m'intéresser à la
politique
ce que je sais c'est que s'il n'y avait
jamais eu de gauche au pouvoir les
ouvriers travailleraient toujours
jusqu'à 65 ans voire même pourquoi pour
pourquoi pas un peu plus mais si ça
serait ça la réalité et quand vous nous
dites que vous ne voulez pas que vos
enfants travaillent
vous inquiétez pas vous aurez la suite
au prochain numéro
merci
monsieur Lurel
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président notre
rapporteur étant général un homme
pondéré
j'ose dire raisonnable et c'est vrai que
ça tonalité n'est pas agressive mais
quelquefois il y a des perles qui
passent et on peut pas laisser faire je
dirais pour la bonne information de tous
personnellement moi en tant que
socialiste je n'ai pas de regret ni de
honte pour la loi Touraine je rappelle
c'était non non mais on l'assume ça et
d'ailleurs ça devrait être la dernière
réforme si on veut élargir le périmètre
des recettes vous vous cantonnez dans un
système qui est le vôtre à savoir il
faut voir faire payer les autres c'est
uniquement les salariés qui devraient
cotiser pour eux-mêmes moi j'estime dans
une conception qui n'est pas extensible
de la répartition que d'autres droits
payés que le capital les dividendes etc
on peut voir un partage
[Musique]
et vous voulez nous enfermer et nous
inoculer un complexe d'infériorité sur
ça je réclame ça as-tu merci Monsieur et
de manière Lucie des conséquente merci
monsieur Lurel la parole est à Monsieur
Boyer
monsieur Boyer
oui merci monsieur le Président alors
effectivement hier je vous ai posé une
petite devinette j'ai l'impression que
il y en a qui n'était pas là donc je
vais la reposer aujourd'hui
si si c'est quand même intéressant parce
que vous parlez de la réforme Touraine
Khadim madame Touraine il y a 10 ans
qu'est-ce qu'elle a dit exactement
il faut l'allongement de la durée de
cotisation
allongement de la durée de cotisation
sans réforme le système de retraite va
droit dans le mur elle l'a dit il y a 10
ans
vous entendez bien ce que je dis là
il faut demander aux Français de
travailler plus longtemps il faut
demander aux Français de travailler plus
longtemps il y en a ici qui l'ont voté
alors pourquoi à cette époque pourquoi
cette Evo à cette époque vous n'avez pas
sorti tous ces arguments que vous nous
sortez aujourd'hui c'est assez
incompréhensible donc je vois qu'il y en
a certaines qui sont gênés c'est vrai
que vous êtes gêné c'est normal que vous
soyez gêné mais je crois que il faut
vous rendre à une évidence il faut vous
rendre à une évidence aujourd'hui qu'il
y a la nécessité d'avancer de trouver
des solutions lorsque l'on aura plus de
retraités que d'actifs ça c'est une
réalité que vous redis régulièrement le
rapporteur n'est pas le Savary il a
beaucoup de mérite de vouloir dire très
souvent mais je voulais encore vous leur
dire une seule fois ça me paraît
important entendez bien entendez bien ce
qu'elle a dit allongement de la durée de
cotisation sans réforme de système de
retraite va droit dans le mur et il faut
demander aux Français de travailler plus
longtemps vous l'avez bien entendu
bien merci je vous propose il y a encore
deux de mon intervention on va les
donner ensuite on va passer au vote sur
cette série d'amendements ou madame
Ferret
merci monsieur le Président alors oui
comme l'a dit ma collègue enfin nous
sommes dans le débat enfin nous sommes
dans la confrontation de je dirais nos
conceptions de la société mais vous nous
interpellez comme si nous étions des
irresponsables comme si nous n'avions
nous avions une mémoire courte mais mes
collègues le rappelaient mes collègues
le rappelaient le contexte de
2013 n'est plus celui d'aujourd'hui mes
collègues le rappelaient tout ce que la
gauche a donné a permis aux Français
d'obtenir pourquoi vous n'en parlez pas
pourquoi vous faites aussi vous avez
cette mémoire courte et ne évoquez pas
ce que la gauche a apporté au peuple
français parce que d'un point de vue
social je suis fier d'être de gauche et
je suis fier de ce que nous avons
apporté alors oui alors oui
vous dites vous dites nous avions
augmenté la durée de cotisation mais
pourquoi brutalement cette fois ci dans
votre réforme vous voulez appliquer
cette réforme cette année en 2023
l'application c'était 2035 vous
considérez qu'il y a une urgence absolue
à précipiter cette réforme et admettre
je dirais les Français dans une nouvelle
situation qui sont qui est injuste
injuste parce que vous demandez au seul
salarié au seul hommes et femmes de
contribuer encore encore à cet effort
que vous demandez vous ne demandez pas
aux entreprises qui ont produit qui ont
créé des profits extrêmement importants
à coup de milliards c'est pas moi qui
dit c'est la réalité cette année encore
nombre une dizaine d'entreprises ont
créé du dividende on crée des profits à
de plusieurs milliards pourquoi de leur
demander vous pas de contribuer ainsi et
enfin vous nous parlez des 43 ans mais
cette réforme ces deux ans de plus pour
tout le monde 64 ans c'est plus que 62
c'est 64 ans c'est deux ans de plus
alors non votre réforme n'est pas une
réforme de gauche
madame la Présidente rossignol
d'abord nous votre pardon nous voterons
ces amendements mais je voulais répondre
aux rapporteur qui nous dit dites la
vérité aux Français vous savez dans
cette affaire c'est pas tant nous le
problème c'est pas nous qui avons mis
les Français dans la rue c'est pas nous
qui avons mobilisé les français pour
qu'ils manifeste comme il le font
exprime leur hostilité à ses très forte
ce sont les organisations syndicales
c'est le front uni la CGT de la CFDT de
Force Ouvrière de solidaire de l'INSA de
la CGC l'ensemble des syndicats et vous
ne serez pas tenir au syndicat le
discours que vous nous tenez à nous par
ailleurs les Français les Français ne
sont pas des gens qu'on manipule avec
des discours politiciens d'ailleurs on
s'en rend compte chaque jour en ce
moment et les Français se souviennent
par exemple en 2010 vous avez été très
fier de passer l'allongement de leur
retour d'âge de deux ans très fier et en
2012 et vu ce qui vous arrivez Sarkozy
battu et battu battu
avec les Français les Français se sont
souvenus en 2012 ce que vous aviez fait
en 2010 la réforme Touraine la réforme
Touraine monsieur nous dit depuis deux
jours la même phrase en boucle la France
appliquait à 2014 à 2014 et non pas
aujourd'hui et justement cette phrase là
dans une contexte totalement différent
de celui d'aujourd'hui sur la question
des déficits des contes de la sécurité
sociale a permis que nous n'avions pas
aujourd'hui la durée de cotisation ni
l'âge dorée du travail mais ce que vous
faites vous le faites sur la base de
prévisions qui sont des prévisions non
pas fondé mais des prévisions
idéologiques c'est ça que vous le choix
que vous avez fait parce que votre
objectif c'est de donner des gages
donner des gages régulièrement le
président de la République nous disons
des 35 heures tout le mal qui pense des
statut social des Français tout le mal
qui pense de ce pays avec ses acquis
sociaux des congés payés des Français
qui sont des fainéants les gages c'est
ça votre politique et c'est des Français
qui vont payer vos gages si c'est très
forme aboutissait et nous ferons tout
pour qu'elle n'aboutissent pas
bon alors écoutez je vous propose irai
dire encore deux qui lève la main à
droite à gauche ou alors donner la
parole et ensuite on va passer au vote
donc monsieur Hainaut et Madame Poncet
Monge monsieur et non oui merci monsieur
le Président Monsieur les ministres au
fond c'est un débat extrêmement
intéressant disons-le assez clivé
totalement clivé mais il est extrêmement
clivé sur la valeur travail voyez c'est
ça qui fait la différence entre nous
c'est que j'entends on a volé deux ans
aux Français mais enfin franchement
c'est pas parce qu'on travaille deux ans
de plus qu'on vole deux ans de vie tout
de même ça n'a rien à voir et combien
ici et même et même chez vous combien
ici se réalise par le travail et
s'épanouissent par le travail en toute
objectivité vous parlez encore comme si
on était au 18e siècle et Émile
Verhaeren que les sirènes se taisent
mais c'est pas ça aujourd'hui le travail
le travail c'est l'épanouissement alors
qu'on discute de la qualité au travail
qu'on discute de la rémunération qu'on
discute de la formation tout au long de
la vie oui mais je vous citerai il faut
toujours un peu de poésie Jules Renard
qui disait le travail pense la
paraisseront
la vie fleurie par le travail je vous
remercie mes chers collègues
madame Poncet Monge madame Poncet Monge
oui merci monsieur le Président moi je
voudrais répondre à René Paul Savary qui
essaie de nous démontrer c'est
régulièrement que de toute façon seul
compte les faits Touraine j'ai bien
compris donc je me demande du coup
pourquoi vous déplacez l'âge et si seul
compte les 43 ans je vous propose déjà
de mettre l'âge de départ à 60 ans c'est
une revendication des écologistes voilà
parce que pourquoi et pourquoi
faites-vous cette erreur je m'explique
assez vite vous dites l'âge moyen du
fait de l'effet Touraine fait qu'on part
à 63 ans etc donc nous on change rien 64
ans on ajoute quelques mois mais c'est
l'âge moyen monsieur le rapporteur il y
en a qui partent à 62 il y en a qui
partent à 62 et demi d'autres à 63 ans
il y a un cadre sur deux qui part à 63
ans ce 4 sur 2 vous allez à rester et
tous ces gens qui partaient avant 64 ans
et qui sont quand même importants ils
vont devoir aller à 64 donc
mécaniquement l'âge moyen va se déplacer
alors dans plus ou moins progressivement
enfin sur 5 ans mais ce que je veux dire
c'est que l'âge moyen ne justifie pas
que vous portiez là je les gale à l'âge
moyen parce que c'est moyen enfin le bon
sens quelquefois c'est la terre est
plate elle est ronde et là l'âge moyen
non les faits de l'âge là devient plus
important que les fêtes Touraine laissez
les gens arbitrer et éventuellement
partir avec des cotes c'est ce que vous
empêchez en mettant l'âge légal de 62 à
64 ans c'est pour ça que la CGC dit que
c'est une loi liberticide je pense
qu'elle pense à ces quatre sur deux qui
vont devoir contre leur grille rester
encore un an au travail dans des
organisations de travail souvent
toxiques
bien merci alors il y a des mains qui se
lèvent mais je propose qu'on passe au
vote c'est un débat passionnant que nous
allons poursuivre que nous allons
poursuivre à l'occasion je pense
d'autres amendements donc sur cette
série d'amendements je vais les
soumettre un parent
au vote d'autant qu'il y a sur certains
d'entre eux sur deux d'entre eux des
demandes de scrutin public donc quand on
en sera là je vous le dirai donc nous
commençons par l'amendement 2975
présenté par le groupe socialiste qui
est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté
l'amendement 2630 qui a été présenté
également par des sénateurs socialistes
qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient n'est pas adopté donc sur
l'amendement
284 j'ai été saisi d'une demande de
scrutin public par le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen écologiste la vie de
la commission est défavorable la vie du
Gouvernement est défavorable il va être
procédé au scrutin public dans les
conditions fixées par l'article 56 du
règlement le scrutin est ouvert
personne ne demande à voter pardon
le scrutin est clos
votons 343 exprimé 335 pour 91 contre
244 le Sénat n'a pas adopté je passe à
l'amendement
[Musique]
4283 présenté par le groupe communiste
qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient n'est pas adopté le 4282
présenté par le groupe communiste même
vote
le
4281 même vote
mbot le 4280 même vote
le 4279 même vote
le 4278
le 4277 même vote
le 4276 même vote
le 4275 même vote
le 4264 même vote le 4273 vote
4272 même vote
4271 même vote
4270 même vote
4269 même vote
4346 j'ai été saisi d'une demande de
scrutin public par le groupe CRCE la vie
de la commission est défavorable à vie
du Gouvernement est défavorable il va
être procédé au scrutin public dans les
conditions fixées par l'article 56 du
règlement le scrutin est ouvert
scrutin et clos
votons 343 exprimé 336 pour 91 contre
245 le Sénat n'a pas adopté enfin le
4344 présenté par le groupe communiste
qui est pour
qui contre
qui s'abstient et n'est pas adopté et le
4345 par le groupe communiste même vote
même vote nous avons donc fini avec
cette série d'amendements en discussion
commune
et nous continuons avec le
2882 nous attaquons une discussion avec
deux amendements de discussion commune
de 1882 présenté par Monsieur gilet je
vous remercie monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre c'est amendement de
notre groupe visa moduler à la hausse
les cotisations patronales d'assurance
vieillesse en fonction des politiques
salariales d'emploi et de formation des
entreprises ainsi que du respect
d'objectif écologique et
environnementaux en fait il s'agit de
mettre en perspective l'action de
l'entreprise dans sa responsabilité
sociétale donc le taux de cotisation
d'assurance vieillesse la charge de
l'employeur pourrait être majorée en
fonction du nombre de fin de contrat de
travail à l'exclusion des démissions la
nature du contrat de travail et sa durée
la politique salariale de l'entreprise
notamment de l'objectif d'égalité
professionnelle politique de formation
de l'entreprise du respect par
l'entreprise d'engagement écologique et
environnementaux dans le cas de la
responsabilité sociale de la taille de
l'entreprise dans les entreprises d'au
moins 50 salariés le comité social et
économique serait donc consultés sur
l'application du présent article au
titre de ces attributions consultatives
mentionnées à l'article suffisait du
Code du travail son avis serait transmis
à une commission spécifique de la Caisse
nationale d'assurance vieillesse les
modalités de calcul de la majoration de
cotisations patronales et de contrôle
des représentants du personnel serait
donc déterminés par des prêts en Conseil
d'État l'intérêt donc de cet amendement
et bien de placer l'entreprise dans sa
responsabilité sociétale et donc
d'introduire une question de bonus malus
au niveau des entreprises comme les
salariés et les retraités peuvent avoir
un bonus et un malus et c'est équité en
termes de présentation serait
particulièrement intéressante ça serait
donc une une forme d'agilité aujourd'hui
dans l'accompagnement des dispositifs de
retraite pour tracer une trajectoire qui
serait donc vertueuse et accompagnée au
mieux les parcours professionnels des
salariés merci le 3141 madame Poncet
Monge
merci monsieur le Président alors cet
amendement se propose de reprendre le
dispositif du malus
des ruptures de contrat cours dans les
secteurs si une entreprise enregistre un
nombre de licenciements des salariés à
partir de 55 ans
au-dessus d'un certain seuil à fixer
après consultation éventuellement des
enfin pas éventuellement des
organisations syndicales mais à fixer
par décret on regarde sa branche donc
elle aurait ce malus alors nous allons
ajouter deux ans à l'âge d'ouverture des
droits à la retraite mais il est grand
temps quand même d'écouter les
enseignements de la loi de 2010 qui est
passé de 60 à 62 ans j'ai déjà dit que
les effets seront plus graves selon
l'INSEE en 2017 le relèvement de deux
ans
lors de la réforme de 2010 s'est traduit
certes par une hausse c'est ce que j'ai
prouvé précédemment mécanique de 14
points 14 points du taux d'emploi 60 ans
etc mais de 13 points du taux de chômage
et de 7 points pour la validité maladie
notons qu'une partie de cette hausse
d'emploi est due à un effet
générationnel notamment pour les femmes
et non au sol relèvement de là-haut
là au départ donc même les câbles ne
sont pas épargnés les nids en emploi ni
en retraite représente 13% des 61 ans et
80% des 100000 cadres de plus de 55 ans
au chômage on fait l'objet préalablement
d'un licenciement et c'est bien c'est
licenciement que nous voulons ici
pointer et taxer
actuellement elle est seniors sont un
million quatre à être au chômage dont
une grande majorité je passe les
chiffres le son depuis plus d'un an le
nombre des demandeurs d'emploi en
catégorie A de plus de 50 ans a
nettement augmenté de surcroît il s'agit
dans ces cas-là de chômeurs de longue
durée la durée moyenne de chômage des
plus de 50 ans était de 370 jours elle
est aujourd'hui 665 jours voilà toutes
les raisons pour lesquelles je demande
merci nous demandons l'instauration de
sommeil merci avis de la commission sur
ces deux amendements
oui dans ces deux amendements vous
proposez d'augmenter les cotisations
vieillesse là encore ce sont des charges
et je le répète ce sont des charges pour
les entreprises supplémentaires
je pense que lorsque nous avons parlé de
l'index senior quand nous avons parlé du
CDI et bien nous avons madame pensée
Mons je parlais aussi des incitations
pour que les entreprises
accueillent des seniors ou en tout cas
puissent les garder dans l'entreprise ce
sont des outils parmi tant d'autres sans
doute que ce n'est pas suffisant je
l'entends bien mais nous préférons les
incitations et le dialogue social plutôt
que les mesures coercitives c'est pour
ça que la commission a émis un avis
défavorable
merci monsieur le Président oui il y a
déjà un système de bonus malus pour les
secteurs qui utilisent beaucoup des
contrats courts
on l'a mis en place vous avez sur les
cotisations ATMP déjà une modulation
selon la sinistralité le nombre
d'accidents du travail là ce que vous
proposez c'est pas un système de bonus
malus c'est tout simplement un malus
c'est-à-dire une augmentation de
cotisations patronales pour les
entreprises qui renchériraient le coût
du travail moi je pense qu'il faut
d'abord se fonder sur les dispositifs
qui existent déjà en la matière
bien donc un double avis défavorable sur
ces deux amendements madame ponce
oui je reprends la parole simplement
pour répondre
pour redire ce que j'ai dit pourquoi pas
un malus bonus et qu'un malus parce que
à l'époque de l'instauration du bonus
malus je m'étais quand même un petit peu
alerté du fait qu'une entreprise il lui
suffisait de faire mieux que la médiane
de son secteur
mais si le secteur était
particulièrement mauvais quoi
c'est-à-dire avait des taux de rupture
et on avait un certain nombre de
branches qu'on connaissait très bien
qu'il y avait un taux de rupture
décontracours absolument phénoménale par
rapport aux autres secteurs de leur de
l'économie française et bien il lui
suffisait cette entreprise de faire
mieux dans son secteur très dégradé pour
avoir un bonus et donc elle pouvait
avoir un taux qui était inférieur à des
branches vertueuses donc c'est pour ça
que j'ai parlé que du malus et enfin il
ne s'agit voit ici si vous voulez
d'inciter dans ce cet amendement madame
la rapporteur a réembauché ce que
éventuellement certains auront débauché
et là c'est effectivement votre
proposition de
seniors mais il s'agit tout simplement
de pénaliser ceux qui licencie voilà
avant de les embaucher ce qu'il faut
arrêter c'est le flux des licenciements
des seniors parce qu'ils coûtent trop
cher ou parce qu'ils ne peuvent pas
suivre le rythme de travail l'intensité
du travail dans les entreprises
merci donc nous avons un double avis
défavorable sur ces deux amendements je
vais les soumettre au voir le premier le
2882 qui est pour
qui contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté le
deuxième le 3141 qui est pour
qui contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté je passe ensuite à l'amendement
4347 présentée par Madame parillas
par cet amendement nous proposons de
majorer les cotisations vieillesse des
entreprises qui n'ont pas conclu de plan
d'égalité professionnelle entre les
femmes et les hommes les inégalités
salariales tout le monde le sait
persiste selon l'Observatoire des
inégalités les femmes perçoivent un
salaire
28,5% inférieur à celui des hommes une
part de ce phénomène s'explique par la
précarité des femmes à l'emploi avec
niveau de temps partiel subit
rappelons-le bien sûr culminant à 28,1%
contre
7,6% pour les hommes mais emploi et
attend de travail strictement équivalent
l'écart est toujours de 5,3% c'est la
proportion discrimination la plus basse
des femmes au travail pourtant le
principe d'égalité salariale est un
principe qui a été maintes fois énoncé à
l'article 23 de la Déclaration
universelle des droits de l'homme du 10
décembre 48
promu par l'Organisation internationale
du travail dans une convention ratifiée
par la France en 1952 inscrit à
l'article 119 du traité de Rome du 25
mars 1957 le principe a travaillé égal
salaire égal introduit dans notre corpus
législatif également par la loi du 22
décembre 1972 nous devrions donc à Taman
encore monsieur le ministre Olivier du
soft vous annoncier à l'occasion de
l'article 2 sur l'index des seniors des
résultats positifs qui seraient
présentés la semaine prochaine en
matière d'égalité professionnelle il
serait souhaitable que vous puissiez
nous apporter des précisions car ce ne
sont pas tout à fait les données dont
nous disposons le principe à travailler
égal salaire égal est une revendication
primaire fondamentale qui générerait pas
moins des 11 milliards d'euros de
cotisations supplémentaires
5,5 milliards d'euros net à terme
nous savons tous que les salaires sont
des cotisations et nous ne devons jamais
l'oublier votons cette amendement de
justice pour les femmes et pour
accroître les recettes de notre régime
par répartition merci Madame Barilla si
nous saluons effectivement monsieur
Duchamps qui nous a rejoint pour cet
après-midi
avis de la commission sur cette
amendement je vous préviens je suis
saisi d'une demande de scrutin public
sur cet amendement donc préparez-vous
allez-y madame la rapporteur défavorable
défavorable monsieur le ministre
défavorable donc double avis défavorable
donc j'ai été saisi d'une demande de
scrutin public sur cet amendement
je vous rappelle que la Commission donc
et le gouvernement donné un double avis
défavorable donc il va être procédé au
scrutin public dans les conditions
fixées par l'artiste 56 du règlement
scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
le scrutin
votant 343 exprimé 342 pour 91 contre
251 le Sénat n'a pas adopté
amendement
4349 madame la Présidente assassin merci
monsieur le Président je voudrais me
permettre quelques petits rappels Sanofi
c'est près de 1700 suppressions de poste
en 2020 et une distribution de
dividendes de plus de 4 milliards
d'euros BNP Paribas première banque
française entend supprimer 921 poste en
France alors même que la maison mère a
affiché en 2022 à bénéfice net record de
plus de 10 milliards d'euros Novartis
près de 400 emplois risque d'être
supprimés en France alors que
l'entreprise affiche en 2021 52
milliards de dollars de chiffre
d'affaires Microsoft près de 206
salariés sur la sellette soit 10% de ces
effectifs cela alors même que la filiale
française connaît une forte croissance
alors ces exemples viennent s'ajouter
quand même à une liste toujours plus
importante d'entreprises qui ont
bénéficié bénéficier et bénéficier
encore largement des 200 êtres publiques
recensés d'exonération en tout genre et
de la baisse massive de la fiscalité du
capital je citerai Renault Airbus Valeo
Vallourec et cette liste est loin d'être
exhaustive or le chômage est un
véritable fléau pour la société bien
évidemment comme pour les avidus
individus la mortalité des chômeurs et
trois fois supérieure à celle des
personnes en emploi et on estime le
nombre de morts par an à plus de 14000
notamment à cause des suicides et nous
vous l'avons dit à répéter cette réforme
est une machine à fabriquer de la
précarité et du chômage en particulier
pour les femmes et les personnes en fin
de carrière
la mise en concurrence des seniors avec
d'autres actifs des gradera l'accès à un
emploi pour d'autres catégories donc les
jeunes les femmes les personnes au
chômage ainsi que les Conditions
Générales de travail des actifs c'est
pourquoi notre amendement vise à faire
davantage contribuer les entreprises de
plus de 50 salariés qui pratiquent des
licenciements économiques à notre sens
injustifié qui n'ont pour que qui n'ont
pour seul objectif que d'améliorer les
bénéfices pour se conformer aux
exigences du marché je vous remercie
merci avis de la commission sur cet
amendement
favorable défavorable monsieur le
ministre défavorable donc un double avis
défavorable monsieur gay
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres mes chers collègues
l'amendement présenté par la présidente
assassy et un très bon amendement et un
amendement important parce que la
question qui nous est posée n'est pas de
savoir s'il faut prendre les deux plus
belles années
de l'âge à la retraite à des millions et
des millions de travailleurs et
travailleuses la seule question qui
devrait nous animer
cet après-midi et les prochaines
semaines c'est de gagner la bataille de
l'emploi on nous dit et on ne cesse de
nous répéter que le pays est en train de
se réindustrialiser après la crise du
covid et partout on s'aperçoit que c'est
faux là elle vient de donner un certain
nombre de chiffres et d'éléments sur la
aérien Air France étant de sous-traitant
une sous-traitant mais aussi beaucoup
d'usines prenons les fonderies
bientôt il n'y aura plus une seule
fonderie en France c'est ça la réalité
du quotidien et donc aujourd'hui les
pièces détachées notamment de nos
véhicules Renault seront fabriqués
demain en Espagne ou en Allemagne ou de
l'autre côté de la planète voici la
réalité et donc
et donc la bataille qui devrait nous
animer ici c'est celle de gagner la
bataille pour l'emploi parce que nous
cessons de vous le dire 1 million de
travailleurs et de travailleurs de plus
en activité c'est moins d'abord de
d'allocations chômage mais c'est surtout
10 milliards de cotisations nets de
suite et donc si la perspective dans le
même temps c'est 10 milliards déficits
nous n'en n'avons plus si nous remettons
un million de travailleurs et de
travailleurs en activité et donc je
trouve dommage que sur un amendement que
nous venons proposer il n'est pas un
débat qui s'engage sur comment
réellement réindustrialiser le pays et
non pas des déclarations d'intention qui
sont en réalité que la communication
politique
bien merci donc double avis défavorable
sur cet amendement je vais le soumettre
aux voix un moment 4349 qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté
ensuite l'amendement
2881 madame meunier
merci monsieur le Président c'est
amendement du groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicains vise à
augmenter d'un point le taux de
cotisation d'assurance vieillesse comme
le préconise le comité
consultation
des retraites d'orientation des
retraites le montant total des
cotisations versées au régime des
retraites s'élevaient en 2021 à 227
milliards d'euros d'après le Haut
Commissariat aux plantes une hausse de
l'ordre de 1 point des cotisations
patronales retraite les augmenteraient
de quelques 7 milliards 500 millions
soit environ 15% du besoin de
financement annuel moyen calculer d'ici
2047 une telle hausse requerrait de
faire passer le taux des cotisations
retraite employeur à 17,5% du salaire
brut contre 16,5% actuellement cette
recette
supplémentaire entre autres pistes
permettrait donc d'améliorer
significativement le financement de la
branche retraite
merci avis de la commission
nous l'avons déjà dit nous ne voulons
pas augmenter les charges de
l'entreprise donc cette un avis
défavorable de la commission
sur le ministre
avis défavorable j'ajoute que selon une
évaluation de la DARES un point
d'augmentation des cotisations
patronales ce que vous proposez ici
c'est 60 000 emplois détruits donc après
voilà il faut décider 120 000 180000
pouvaient fixer des objectifs en
centaines de milliers d'emplois détruits
à ce moment-là faut augmenter d'un peu
plus de 4 points mais en tout cas avec
un point c'est 60000 l'estimation de la
DARES on souhaite que les gens puissent
évidemment travailler et vivre de leur
travail donc avis défavorable
donc un double avis défavorable monsieur
Lurel
j'aimerais pouvoir dire à Monsieur le
Ministre ce n'est pas avéré
économétriquement et ni même en théorie
économique on avance ça
à savoir qu'il y a une sorte
d'élasticité entre le niveau
d'imposition et le nombre de d'emplois
créés ce n'est pas prouvé ce n'est pas
avéré donc ça c'est le magistère dixit
que vous nous assignez
monsieur gay
merci monsieur le Président regardez du
côté gauche on lève le doigt
c'est
merci monsieur le Président messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues alors
l'argument combien le dire mon collègue
Victorin Lurel était culé c'est-à-dire
que autant
on sait maintenant que les exonérations
de cotisation ne crée pas un seul emploi
augmenter n'en fait pas perdre de plus
ça mais alors on peut avoir un débat
mais tant mieux s'il y a un débat qui
s'ouvre argument contre argument chiffre
et je réponds juste à Madame la
rapporteur sur charge c'est une charge
une charge supplémentaire une charge
supplémentaire on rencontre les
cotisations sociales rencontres beaucoup
de chefs d'entreprise donc au mersant
d'artisans chacun dans nos
circonscriptions moi je vous le dis
depuis plusieurs semaines et plusieurs
mois il y en a pas un qui me dit que les
cotisations sociales sont insupportables
et qui se leur problème numéro 1 par
contre en ce moment
pas on rencontre pas les mêmes mais je
rencontre beaucoup pas un par contre ce
qui nous disent voyez vous prenez
souvent la défense des boulangers il
commence par vous dire quoi les
boulangers en ce moment c'est les
cotisations sociales ou le prix de
l'électricité
c'est le prix de l'électricité et quand
vous en proposez de sortir du marché
européen de l'énergie vous avez voté
contre quand vous a proposé le retour au
tarif réglementé vous avez voté contre
et il n'y a pas des années il y a
quelques semaines donc ayant un débat
ancré dans le réel pas un chef
d'entreprise aujourd'hui nous dit que
les cotisations sociales sont pour lui
une charge insupportable par contre
l'inflation des produits alimentaires
des produits de première nécessité et le
coût de l'énergie oui donc si on veut
régler les vrais problèmes prenons les
dans l'ordre ayant un débat et quand on
vous fait des propositions pragmatiques
et bon sens veuillez les voter chers
collègues
monsieur le Président Richard
monsieur le Président en quelques mots
bien entendu on pourrait faire cette
intervention à n'importe quel moment
mais si il suffit il suffit qu'on
s'écoute
on pourrait faire cette intervention à
n'importe quel moment ce que je veux
simplement dire c'est que nous avons pu
vérifier que le niveau des recettes
fiscales et sociales qui pèsent
directement sur les salaires et à la
charge des employeurs sont les plus
élevés de l'Union européenne nous avons
moins d'impôts dans d'autres domaines et
notamment des impôts directs sur le
revenu des individus mais nous avons à
taux de prélèvement sur les salaires
versés qui est maximale et
franchement je veux bien faire un coup
un concours d'économétrie avec Monsieur
duren mais de penser que ça n'a aucun
lien avec notre difficulté retrouver la
compétitivité en matière extérieure je
crois que ça se démontre assez aisément
bien nous allons passer nous allons
passer au vote sur cet amendement madame
ronce
non je voulais effectivement dire que
c'est très étonnant cette élasticité que
vous découvrez parce qu'effectivement
c'est une élasticité qu'on n'a jamais vu
à la baisse
on a eu beau exonéré on a eu d'eau aider
les entreprises
ça a jamais créé autant d'emplois que
paraît-il quand on ré augmente d'un
point il y aurait 60 000 en poêle et
tout simplement parce que ça a été dit
parce que la part des salaires dans la
valeur ajoutée enfin par rapport aux
consommations intermédiaires enfin je
veux dire elle est devenue une part
congrue et donc la moindre effectivement
évolution des coûts des consommations
intermédiaires sur lequel vous ne faites
rien puisque il y a quand même des coûts
énergétiques aujourd'hui qui augmentent
de par spéculation et non simplement par
traduction des enfin du problème
géopolitique et bien là vous pesez vous
détruisez plus d'emplois en laissant les
prix là avoir une composante spéculative
forte que le point de cotisation et se
termine quand même sur sur est-ce que
c'est une charge ou une cotisation le
salaire le salaire les cotisations c'est
du salaire socialisé et donc c'est du
salaire ce que vous dites quand vous
dites une charge vous dites le mot il
faut le dire dans ce cas-là j'estime que
le salaire le salaire est une charge et
bien moi je vous dis que pourtant c'est
le salaire qui crée la valeur ajoutée
qui crée la richesse et le salaire n'est
pas une charge non
c'est un coup peut-être à côté des coûts
intermédiaires et donc c'est pareil pour
le salaire socialisé vous n'osez pas
dire ça pour le salaire mais le salaire
socialisé est une composante du salaire
merci Monsieur Duplomb
ouais monsieur le Président mais
monsieur les ministres mes chers
collègues
moi je me suis retenu pendant deux jours
et demi de ne rien dire et ce coup-ci il
me semble qu'il faut quand même
intervenir
ce que je ne comprends pas dans ce débat
d'abord premièrement d'autres l'ont dit
avant moi c'est qu'on a l'impression que
le travail est devenu une valeur d'un
autre pays qui n'a plus aucune valeur et
que par définition et que par définition
il faudrait qu'il soit le plus court
possible le moins pénible possible et
qu'il ne servent le moins possible alors
que je pense qu'au contraire on en dans
un pays où l'émancipation et par le
travail le deuxième élément c'est que ce
que je n'arrive pas à comprendre c'est
qu'on ne réfléchisse que par un seul
prisme nous avons il y a pas si
longtemps dans cet essai dans cette
hémicycle il y a peu de semaines eu à
traiter le problème du chômage nous
avions proposé qu’après un CDD ou après
une période d'intérim une personne à qui
il lui est proposé un CDI que ça soit
après un CDD ou après une période
d'intérim puisse soit avoir le choix de
le refuser ce qui est son et de
continuer de travailler mais ne plus
avoir la possibilité de percevoir le
chômage les mêmes qui nous expliquent
qu'il faut trouver des financements les
mêmes étaient contre cette principe et
pourtant le chômage c'est quoi c'est le
principe de la solidarité pourrait aider
ce qui perdent leur travail non pas pour
laisser la possibilité à celui qui n'a
plus envie de travailler de percevoir le
chômage donc on nous vous ne l'avez pas
voté
et le gouvernement et le gouvernement et
le gouvernement a fini a fini par plier
en acceptant en CMP mais en édulcorance
que nous écrivions ce que nous écrivions
c'était de dire un CDD ou une période
d'intérim ne peut pas refuser ne peut
pas percevoir le chômage quand il refuse
un CDI le gouvernement a voulu qu'il y
ait deux périodes de refus ce qui est
inadmissible à partir d'une fois
[Musique]
monsieur vallée
merci monsieur le Président je pense
qu'on entame un débat qui peut être
intéressant et relever un peu le niveau
d'abord on rassure notre collègue
notre collègue du plan sur le fait qu'il
s'est retenu pendant deux jours on le
dira pas Bruno retaillod ça restera
entre nous le fait qu'il ait brisé la
loi du silence je voudrais dire
également
que j'imagine sur ces banques il y a
quand même des gens pour considérer y
compris à gauche que le travail peut
être quelque chose de sain
peut-être quelque chose de fécond
peut-être même quelque chose de généreux
et puisque nous en sommes à dire à
plusieurs reprises qui si on s'occupe du
Sénat et pas de l'Assemblée nationale le
travail sain fécond et généreux qui rend
le peuple libre et l'homme heureux et
c'est une vision à laquelle vous
souscrivez probablement était celle de
notre émérite prédécesseur dans ces
rangs de Victor Hugo sur ses sièges
mais en ce en citant cet aspect là du
travail c'était pour mieux dénoncer ce
qu'il appelait le contraire du vrai
travail c'est à dire l'exploitation moi
je suis ravi d'avoir entendu un collègue
dire tout à l'heure qu'on n'était pas au
19e siècle
et bien sans démagogie aucune il viendra
l'expliquer aux aides à domicile et je
vous le dis avec émotion que nous avons
tous eu à gérer dans nos collectivités
et qui sont confrontés à de la
pénibilité qui n'est pas prise en compte
et qui est d'autant moins prise en
compte que ces métiers là ont du mal à
se syndiquer ces métiers là ont du mal à
être représentés et à faire entendre
leur voix alors certes on est plus au
19e siècle fort heureusement parce
qu'autrement se débala nous ne pourrions
pas la voir de manière aussi
démocratique mais on ne peut pas nier
qu'il y a aujourd'hui du travail qui à
côté de celui que tout le monde souhaite
et dans lequel il veut être épanoui le
travail sain fait qu'en généreux qui
rend le peuple libre et l'homme heureux
il y a encore des modalités de travail
pour lesquelles il faut prendre en
compte la pénibilité et des gens qui
n'ont pas envie de bosser qui n'ont pas
envie de prendre un boulot qui n'ont pas
envie de participer il en existe
peut-être mais il y en a aussi une
partie et ça s'appelle les rentiers
monsieur Tissot
[Applaudissements]
oui merci monsieur le Président
messieurs les ministres mes chers
simplement
j'ai pas l'impression d'être un sénateur
particulier mais j'ai pas non plus
l'impression d'être hors du temps et
pour reprendre ce que vous disais de nos
collègues tout à l'heure je veux bien
être le site le sénateur représentant
les plus grandes filiales que la terre
est portée ou que la terre porte que
notre pays porte aujourd'hui il s'agit
pas de savoir si on veut continuer
travailler mais c'est de savoir si on
peut continuer de travailler après 62
ans et ne me dites pas de bêtises ne me
dites pas de bêtises quand vous avez
commencé de travailler tôt ou même pas
obligatoirement tôt mais pendant 20 ans
30 ans 35 ans vous avez travaillé dans
dans le froid dans les intempéries à
porter des charges lourdes à partir de
60 ans à partir de 62 ans vous êtes
éreinté fatigué laminé vous n'existez
plus physiquement et vous dites que l'on
peut encore continuer de travailler deux
ans supplémentaires et tout à l'heure le
collègue sénateur je regardais sa page
wikipédia j'ai pas réussi à trouver son
travail mais je pense pas qu'il est
travaillé avec ses mains pendant 40 ans
pour avoir cet avis là et pensez aussi
aux personnes que vous applaudissiez
tous que nous applaudissions tous à 20
il y a deux ans les soignants les
infirmières les médecins les
aides-soignantes les ash comment vous
pouvez oser les regarder encore
aujourd'hui et vous Mesdames et
Messieurs les médecins quand vous les
recevez dans vos cabinets que vous que
qu'est-ce que vous leur dites quand à 62
ans les les aides-soignants vous dites
vous disent mais moi je peux plus faire
les transferts des personnes âgées du
brancard à un lit parce que j'ai le dos
cassé j'ai les bras cassés je les
épaules cassés vous leur dites quoi vous
leur dites m'écoutez vous allez quand
même faire deux ans supplémentaires si
ça mais comment vous pouvez tenir de
tels propos comment pouvez-vous ne pas
être d'accord avec nous quand nous
disons que pour ces gens-là pas pour
tout le monde pas pour tout le monde moi
maintenant aujourd'hui je peux tout à
fait travailler jusqu'à 64 ans jusqu'à
65 ans rassurez-vous c'est bien moins
pénible d'être ici même jusqu'à 2h du
matin 3h du matin 4h du matin que faire
paysan ou travailler dans le bâtiment
rassurez-vous moi j'ai fait tous ces
métiers là et je peux vous garantir que
ces métiers là le rendu plan anti-âge de
la tête vous achetez de la tête chers
collègues sénateur mais vous savez très
bien que j'ai raison vous avez très bien
que mon propos est vrai merci
la présidente la présidente Catherine de
roche a demandé la parole
merci monsieur le Président moi je
voulais vous rappeler quand même que
nous sommes dans un débat qui certes en
effet peut être passionné et c'est
normal puisque on est sur un tel sujet
bon les attaques à nominales sur les
fiches des uns des autres c'est pas
forcément utile
néanmoins néanmoins je vous avais parlé
beaucoup pénibilité là depuis quelques
minutes je vous rappelle que si vous
voulez qu'on avance sur l'article sur la
pénibilité il faudrait peut-être
resserrer le temps
l'article 7 veut être discuter demain
après-midi donc acte je veux bien mais
au rythme on va c'est même pas demain
après-midi je veux dire un moment il
faut aussi quand on prend des
engagements les respecter
bien je vous propose de passer au vote
sur l'amendement 2881 qui vient d'être
présenté par le groupe socialiste qui
est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté nous
passons à l'amendement
3166 présenté par Madame ponce
merci monsieur le Président alors lors
de la présentation de ce projet de
réforme la première ministre Madame
Elisabeth borne admis lors de cette
présentation le 10 janvier de nombreuses
entreprises ont recours à une pratique
abusive voire discriminatoire qui
consiste à faire partir les salariés
quelques années avant la retraite
et donc et donc rien voilà assis l'index
voilà donc une forme d'impuissance
l'État serait impuissant devant ça et
effectivement vu qu'il y a les moyens de
contrôle de l'inspection du travail de
toute façon sur des pratiques je répète
abusives voire discriminatoire étant ce
qu'elles sont cela continuera alors non
effectivement nous nous pensons que il
faut il faut contrôler il faut aussi
sanctionner
les entreprises qui se débarrassent
effectivement des salariés quelques
années avant la retraite alors on nous a
dit la contribution de la lande avait
cette motivation ça a vraiment pas
marché et ce qu'on nous a dit aussi
c'est ça a pas marché et les entreprises
elles ont licencié un an avant bon donc
le comportement des entreprises là étant
ce qu'il est vous voyez mais c'était la
preuve qu'il fallait pas de pénalité
parce que les entreprises licencieraient
avant donc maintenant on nous propose
peut-être de leur donner quelque chose
une prime une exonération pour pas
qu'elle le fasse c'est à dire qu'on
navigue entre un puissance sur un
comportement condamnable et effet
d'aubaine alors non je pense que
effectivement les entreprises ont une
grande responsabilité dans le maintien
en emploi des seigneurs et dans un
contexte effectivement ou beaucoup
considèrent le Seigneur comme des
salariés qui peuvent pas suivre
l'intensification du travail c'est
terminé donc il faut il faut dépénaliser
merci avis de la commission sur cet
amendement
avis défavorable monsieur le ministre
avis défavorable donc double avis
défavorable je le soumets aux voix qui
est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient il n'est
pas adopté l'amendement
2515 monsieur Breuillet Nassim monsieur
le Président Monsieur monsieur le
ministre chers collègue cet amendement
est inspiré par notre ancienne collègue
Sophie tailler polliant dont j'ai pris
la suite et par les députés écologistes
elle vise à instaurer un malus sur les
cotisations écoutez bien avant de rire
sur les cotisations des employeurs pas
de tous les employeurs mais sur les
cotisations du au titre des accidents du
travail et des maladies professionnelles
uniquement pour les entreprises qui
présentent une tendance élevée au
licenciement de travailleurs et de
travailleuses pour inaptitude l'objectif
j'espère que ça ne fait moins rire
l'objectif est multiple inciter les
entreprises à s'engager sur des
politiques opérantes de prévention des
accidents et maladies professionnelles
et éviter au maximum les déclarations
d'inaptitude
s'assurer que les hypothèses de
reclassement sont bel et bien étudiées
au maximum respectés et ainsi d’imiter
au maximum les licenciements pour
inaptitude faire contribuer davantage au
financement de la branche accident du
travail maladie professionnelle des
entreprises moins responsables qui
licencient pour inaptitude des salariés
qui seront ensuite pris en charge par la
Sécurité Sociale d'après l'enquête
Emploi 2012 en 5 ans le taux de
licenciement pour inaptitude a fortement
augmenté il est passé de 4 à 6
licenciements pour 1000 emplois en CDI
50% d'augmentation si le chiffre de 100
000 salariés déclarés inapte à leur
poste et régulièrement avancé de façon
parcellaire il n'existe aucun chiffre au
niveau national qui consolide ce
phénomène ainsi ce dispositif
permettrait en outre d'avoir une vision
globale et des données sur le nombre
d'entreprises qui ont recours à des
licenciements pour inaptitudes cet
amendement renvoie à une définition
réglementaire nécessaire précisant le
taux anormalement élevé de licenciement
qui avant de passer à la vie de la
commission je vous signale j'ai une
demande de scrutin public du groupe
écologiste sur cette amendement avis de
la commission
avis de la commission allez-y monsieur
le rapporteur
oui merci monsieur le Président
effectivement dans l'exposé des motifs
on parle de l'inaptitude au travail qui
est une préoccupation quand même majeure
mais là l'amendement vous parlez de
faire des modifications des pénalités
sur la branche ATMP ça mérite de
souligner la différence l'inaptitude au
travail n'est pas prise en compte comme
l'incapacité permanente qui elle relève
de la branche ATMP qui concerne la
pénibilité quand les salariés sont
exposés au travail quand une usure au
travail à travers les facteurs de
pénibilité qu'il soit pris en compte sur
le C2P qui soit ergonomique qui soit en
chimique tandis quand il y a une
inaptitude de travail ça peut être par
une maladie par d'autres dispositifs ce
n'est pas pris en charge dans le cas de
la branche ATMP faut bien faire la
différence parce que les prises en
charge sont réellement différentes c'est
la raison pour laquelle la branche ATMP
n'étant pas concernée par les problèmes
d'inaptitude nous avons donné un avis
défavorable
monsieur le ministre
donc un avis défavorable également de
monsieur le ministre monsieur Fernique
une explication de vote je crois que le
phénomène des salariés inapte au travail
fait vraiment l'objet d'une
sous-évaluation par les pouvoirs publics
il existe aucun chiffre national
consolidé du nombre d'avis d'inaptitude
attribué vers la médecine du travail à
ces salariés qui ne peuvent pas
reprendre totalement ou parce qu'elles
ment leur emploi initial pourtant plus
de 90% des salariés déclarés inaps sont
licenciés selon un rapport de la Haute
Autorité de Santé la reconnaissance de
cette inaptitude permet de toucher une
indemnité en capital selon le taux
d'incapacité une rente d'incapacité
versée par la Sécurité Sociale chaque
trimestre pour les incapacités
inférieures à 50%. c'est 30 pour
inaptitude qui n'excède pas 25% de leur
salaire de référence est jugé
unanimement faible et ne permet pas de
vivre une fois l'indemnité en capital et
les droits au chômage consommé ainsi en
estimait en 2017 à 100 000 nouveaux
salariés inaptent inscrits chaque année
à Pôle emploi et à 1 à 2 millions le
nombre total de salariés qui seraient
menacés de désinsertion profession un
phénomène qui ne cesse de se renforcer
en raison du report de l'âge de départ à
la retraite car il touche
particulièrement les salariés seniors
ayant eu des métiers physiques et
intervient en moyenne à 60,4 ans pour
les hommes et à 65,9 ans pour les femmes
est une dresse de 2020 même un faible
degré d'inaptitude peut poser
d'importantes difficultés d'insertion
seul 25% des salariés inaptent sont
employés vers des structures sont
envoyées pardon vers des structures
spécialisées dans l'insertion de
travailleurs en situation de handicap et
les conseillers Pôle Emploi ça vous
démuni face à certains cas les réformes
successives de l'assurance chômage sont
venus durcir les conditions
d'indemnisation sans égard pour les
centaines de milliers de salariés qui ne
peuvent plus accéder à la grande
majorité des postes proposés et enfin
pour conclure je dirais que la question
écologique est également à prendre en
considération dans la mesure où les
risques professionnels sont largement
liés aux dangers de la pollution ou
encore des produits chimiques merci de
votre attention
merci donc j'ai été saisi d'une demande
de scrutin public par le groupe
écologique sur cet amendement 2515 avec
un double avis défavorable de la
commission et du gouvernement il va être
procédé au scrutin public dans les
conditions fixées par article 56 du
règlement le scrutin est ouvert
343 exprimé 342 pour 91 contre 251 le
Sénat n'a pas adopté dans deux
amendements qui font l'objet d'une
discussion commune le premier le 3164
monsieur madame poncemonge madame ponce
je crois que le deuxième aussi
3488 donc peut-être vous pouvez
présenter les deux ils sont en
discussion commune
merci monsieur le Président oui je
prends acte de la remarque effectivement
en lisant le dispositif de du rapporteur
donc je lui donne une occasion de
effectivement de d'avoir un avis
défavorable sur mon amendement parce que
c'est pas à la TNT mais effectivement
l'assurance maladie qu'il faudrait
verser des les pénalités autrement il
doit le regretter il aurait très
certainement
approuvé le fait que il faut alors
instaurer une pénalité pas tant pour
parce que on parlait de l'aide à
domicile tout à l'heure et les aides à
domicile désormais partout quel que soit
les organisations fut-elles les plus
vertueuses sortent par inaptitude
massivement alors elle sortiront encore
plus demain avec deux ans de plus mais
surtout sur le fait des entreprises qui
ne font aucun effort enfin qui n'ont pas
un plan soit de prévention ou d'action
pour y remédier c'est à dire il suffit
là pour le coup d'aller voir dans dans
la durée enfin pour ceux qui connaissent
la déclaration unique si effectivement
il y a des actions quand même de
l'entreprise essayons d'être vertueux
par rapport à un risque élevé dans
certaines branches donc c'est toujours
relativement à une branche qu'il faut
faire ça
et moi ce que j'aimerais dire quand même
c'est que le licenciement par inaptitude
est dû aussi aujourd'hui au fait que
dans les entreprises on a beaucoup
externalisé les postes qui étaient
allégés pour des raisons de comparatif
de moins 10 ans de coups quoi et
désormais il y a que les postes les plus
durs donc il est difficile même pour
ceux qui souhaiteraient mais c'est la
conséquence de cette stratégie
d'externalisation
par rapport à une politique de moins 10
ans et à ce propos il faut bien dire que
quelquefois on compare le coût dans les
fonctions publiques des fonctionnaires
par rapport au privé et bien le privé
externalise le coût social de ces de ces
salariés qui ont des difficultés à
suivre un petit peu le poste de travail
le privé externaliste sur la société et
la fonction publique quelle que soit
dans les trois ordres les gardes
essaient de trouver des postes adaptés
alors quelquefois c'est de là que vient
le différentiel de coup quand on veut
privatiser certains certains services de
la fonction publique
vous avez présenté les deux amendements
donc Madame poncer
avis de la commission sur ces deux
amendements
merci Raymonde pour ces mots je vous
avais bien compris le dispositif que
l'inaptitude effectivement correspondait
à l'assurance maladie et que c'était
l'incapacité permanente qui
correspondait à la TP mais
Raymonde permettez-moi de vous dire
qu'il y a quand même quelque chose qu'il
faut rétablir on ne prend pas deux ans
de plus par l'inaptitude le la retraite
anticipée pour une aptitude aujourd'hui
est à 62 ans c'est l'âge légal demain
dans la loi la retraite par aptitude
sera sur un agent anticipé 64 - 2 mais
restera 62 ans
j'aurais préféré qu'on voit les choses
différemment parce que je partage vos
préoccupations sur l'inaptitude j'aurais
bien essayé de descendre un petit peu
l'âge mais Monsieur le Ministre m'a dit
que ce serait pas raisonnable et il me
fallait son avis pour effectivement
sortir du droit actuel voilà tandis que
l'incapacité permanente qui vous
préoccupe vous allez voir qu'on fait des
propositions et on par rapport aux
propositions de Monsieur le Ministre et
qui m'en veut beaucoup parce que ça va
coûter un peu de sous donc j'ai besoin
de son autorisation je voudrais la
descendre à 60 ans voyez-vous le droit
actuel quand même qui oui à 60 ans - 2
vous voyez pour rester dans le
dispositif actuel mais si vous avez
cette impatience
de délibérer sur l'inaptitude de
délibérer sur l'incapacité permanente
attendez l'article 8 et l'article 9 et
invançons dans les débats parce que ça
c'est une préoccupation de nos
concitoyens
avis de Monsieur le Ministre
même avis du gouvernement madame ponce
oui monsieur le rapporteur mais j'étais
sur l'inaptitude que vous l'avez dit
qu'il relève de l'assurance maladie et
pas sur l'incapacité permanente mais
vous avez raison pour l'incapacité
permanente il n'y a pas de changement
il pouvait partir à 62 ans ils peuvent
toujours partir à 62 ans c'est pourquoi
effectivement ce n'est pas une mesure
d'accompagnement mais si les ministres
et donc en aucun cas ils doivent être
marqués comme venant se soustraire des
18 milliards que vous allez économiser
soit par la baisse des pensions soit par
les apports contributifs de ce laitier
qui continueront à travailler donc par
contre si vous passez si vous entendez
le rapporteur général et que vous passez
l'incapacité permanente à 60 ans Alors
là Monsieur le Ministre ça sera une
mesure d'accompagnement et vous pourrez
déduire les 3 milliards que vous avez
indument mis sur une sur une mesure qui
n'est que le maintien et qui n'est en
aucun cas un seul coup
bien merci donc sur ces deux amendements
je suis saisi d'une demande de scrutin
public
oui par le groupe
écologie solidarité territoire sur le
premier de ces deux amendements
l'amendement 3174 avec un double avis
défavorable de la commission et du
gouvernement il va être procédé au
scrutin public dans les conditions
fixées par l'article 56 de règlement le
scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin
343 exprimé 342 pour 91 comptes 251 le
Sénat n'a pas adopté est-ce que je peux
considérer que nous avons le même vote
sur le
3488 qui a été présenté en même temps
oui donc même vote
nous passons ensuite à l'amendement
2461 monsieur ferrique
et monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je remplace la Thomas docius
notre collègue qui propose au nom du
groupe écologiste solidarité territoire
c'est amendement qui vise à créer une
contribution exceptionnelle pour les
entreprises qui enregistreraient un taux
de licenciement pour inaptitude
supérieure à la moyenne de la branche
concernée en ce qui concerne leurs
salariés de plus de 59 ans la situation
professionnelle des seniors est souvent
critique on l'a compris de nombreux
salariés depuis 55 ans sont mis à la
porte du jour au lendemain par leurs
employeurs respectifs sans raison
apparente je rappelle après ma collègue
Raymonde que la première ministre
Elisabeth borne l'a d'ailleurs ici même
à 1000 lors de la présentation du projet
de réforme qualifiant cette pratique qui
consiste à faire partir les salariés
quelques années avant la retraite je
cite d'abusive voire de discriminatoires
c'est elle qui le disait ces employés
licenciés peinent à retrouver du travail
et font face à tout un tas de préjugés
les employeurs craignent qu'ils aient
des problèmes présenter ou qu'il demande
une rémunération trop importante
résultat d'après une récente étude de la
DARES le taux d'emploi des 54 64 ans
s'élève à 56 en 56 56% pardon en France
un chiffre bien en dessous de la moyenne
européenne qui est au-dessus de 60 selon
vous monsieur le ministre la réforme des
retraites favoriserait l'emploi les
travailleurs seniors et donc le plein
emploi en réalité la réforme excluera du
marché du travail c'est même travailleur
c'est le constat qui a été fait à chaque
décalage de l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite comme avec la réforme verte en
2010 ainsi en 2019 16% des personnes de
plus de 50 ans n'étaient ni en emploi ni
à la retraite pour ces personnes
décalées là je légale c'est simplement
être plus longtemps au chômage ou au
minima sociaux ça a été dit la situation
des plus de 59 ans va donc s'aggraver
contrairement à ce que Monsieur le
Ministre votre gouvernement essaie de
nous faire croire parce que cette
situation est insupportable nous
proposons donc instaurer une
contribution exceptionnelle dans le but
de dissuader les entreprises de
licencier leurs employés depuis 59 ans
de manière abusive merci avis de la
commission
oui merci là encore l'exposé des motifs
ne correspond pas à l'objet de
l'amendement
faudrait prendre pour habitude quand
même ce que nous pratiquons
régulièrement c'est-à-dire présenter nos
amendements en fonction de l'objet là il
s'agit de pénalité qui est à la cnaval
ce qui est pas mal ça renforé le budget
de la CNAV mais des pénalités
supplémentaires pour les entreprises qui
enregistrent un taux de licenciement
pour inaptitude donc c'est bien la CNAV
il y a pas de problème
inaptitude des salariés plus de 59 ans
supérieure à la moyenne de leur branche
peut arriver qu'il y ait des accidents
et si un taux d'inaptitude à 58 ans ils
sont pas concernés par la mesure à 59
ans on discutait des effets de bornes
j'ai cru comprendre tout à l'heure vous
étiez pas
tellement intéressé par les bornes en
tout cas on critique les bornes quand ça
nous plaît pas mais on en fait l'éloge
quelques minutes après en conséquence
nous avons nous la même cohérence donc
avis défavorable pour des pénalités
supplémentaires nous pensons qu'il vaut
mieux faire des plans de prévention de
l'inaptitude
avis de Monsieur le Ministre
donc même avis double avis des favorable
je suis saisi d'une demande de scrutin
public par le groupe écologiste sur
l'amendement
2461 avec un double avis défavorable
il va être procédé au vote dans ce que
dans les conditions etc le scrutin est
ouvert
demande à voter le scrutin est clos
143 exprimé 342 pour 90 contre 252 le
Sénat n'a pas adopté ensuite deux
amendements discussions
identiques en discussion commune le
2875 madame briquet
visa
visa financer le fond pour la prévention
de l'usure professionnelle dans les
hôpitaux et établissements sociaux et
médico-sociaux par un malus de
cotisations patronales sur
l'accidentologie au travail aujourd'hui
nous le savons tous nos hôpitaux
manquent de personnel et peine
aujourd'hui à recruter du fait aussi de
la pénibilité un des métiers concernés
ce malus ne serait qu'un juste retour
des choses pour améliorer les conditions
de travail dans ce secteur
particulièrement sensible et au combien
indispensable pour nos concitoyens
merci et donc amendement identique le
3171 madame poncemonge
merci monsieur le Président alors comme
c'est de nouveau un malus et avons je
vais m'abriter derrière le rapport de la
Cour des comptes sur les politiques de
prévention en santé au travail dans les
entreprises rapport de décembre 2022 qui
critique le manque d'ambition de la
politique publique donc de l'État en
matière de santé au travail et de
prévention des risques professionnels et
je le cite l'absence de contraintes qui
pèse sur les entreprises bien donc si la
Cour des comptes le dit je m'autorise à
le dire aussi je ne reviens pas sur les
chiffres quand même des contraintes de
la DARES vous avez cité la DARES sur les
contraintes physiques et aussi les
contraintes de rythme de travail
mais si je reviens pas sur sur ces
chiffres quand même j'espère monsieur le
rapporteur que
quand nous discuterons de l'article sur
la pénibilité
on verra s'ils sont les mesures les
propositions que vous faites s'ils sont
à la hauteur de l'explosion
multiplication par 3 ou multiplication
par 4 quel que soit les catégories
socio-professionnelles de ces
contraintes de pénibilité physique et de
contraintes temporelles parce que c'est
ça qu'il faut voir c'est un est-ce qu'il
tienne compte de cette explosion et de
est-ce que la population qui est quand
même plus vulnérable et moins résistante
je dirais devant ces contraintes
physiques et contraintes temporaires qui
vont devoir temporels vont devoir
travailler de 62 à 64 ans est-ce que
seront en mesure de rester dans
l'activité du travail je vous remercie
si avis de la commission sur ces deux
amendements
il s'agit encore de pénalité mais
effectivement en rapport avec la branche
ATMP donc même motif même sanction avis
défavorable ou Raymond poncemont je
n'hésitais pas à le retirer si vous le
souhaitez
mais ma vie de Monsieur le Ministre donc
je vais soumettre aux voix ces deux
amendements identiques et pour
qui contre
qui s'abstient ils ne sont pas adoptés
je passe à l'amendement
2329 présenté par Monsieur Hainaut oui
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre on est d'accord au fond au
travers ce débat de considérer que
l'emploi des seniors est une question
essentielle et c'est un amendement qui
résulte d'une discussion avec un patron
éclairé avec des préoccupations sociales
et donc ce qui est évoqué c'est la
question de l'exonération on aurait
préféré la prime mais ok pour
l'exonération mais que se passe-t-il
notamment quand il y a rupture
d'engagement et donc je sais pas si
c'est un amendement d'appel si c'est un
amendement qui veut lancer le débat mais
entendre le rapporteur sur cette
question que se passe-t-il en cas de la
rupture d'engagement si le CDI ne va pas
à son terme et il me paraîtrait
judicieux ça n'est pas une sanction
c'est la logique du juste retour que les
exonérations dont attiré le bénéfice
l'entreprise puis cette remboursée au
cas où il n'y aurait pas respect des
engagements qui ont été pris à
l'embauche je vous remercie et je ne
veux m'interroger aussi de savoir s'il
faut légiférer deuxième question que je
veux aborder puisque étant attaché au
paritarisme et à la discussion avec les
partenaires sociaux bien évidemment si
on aborde toutes les questions
législatives et de droit dans une
logique d'entonnoir alors on laisse pas
suffisamment de grains à moudre
partenaires sociaux voilà le l'objet de
cet amendement qui veut poser sur la
table tous ces sujets je vous remercie
merci monsieur le rapporteur
merci Olivier et nous il y a les
questions et les réponses à l'intérieur
de l'intervention mais le sujet
effectivement est celui-là vous proposez
déplacer les bornes à 57 ans alors déjà
monsieur le ministre tous je dirais
entre guillemets par rapport à nos
propositions qui sont estimées à un prix
probibitif quand on met l'âge de 60 ans
vous pensez à 57 ans effectivement ça
devient là un peu plus encore effet
d'aubaine si est fait d'aubaine il y a à
vérifier le CDI senior est en train un
CDI différent du CDI classique il
appartiendra au partenaires sociaux de
le préciser justement pour marquer la
différence parce que sinon je partage
l'effet d'aubaine donc faut bien marquer
la différence et ensuite effectivement
c'est le dispositif
qui pourrait être intéressant si vous
bénéficiez d'exonération que vous tenez
pas l'engagement pour tenir votre
salarié jusqu'à ce qu'il soit au taux
plein ou à l'âge d'annulation de la
décote mais quelque part l'engagement
pas tenu et il peut y avoir
répercussions et remboursement des
exonérations dont on a bénéficié
cependant je pense que véritablement et
c'était la fin de votre intervention qui
vaut mieux laisser les partenaires
sociaux délibérés là-dessus et puis
ensuite prendre nos responsabilités et
nous aurons l'occasion de prendre nos
responsabilités puisque le monsieur le
ministre du travail s'est engagé à nous
présenter la loi travail après les
discussions avec les partenaires sociaux
à travers la nid mais également à
travers d'autres dispositifs notamment
l'intéressement je crois que c'est comme
ça que l'on dit de salariés par rapport
à l'entreprise qui est là aussi quelque
chose qui peut être pertinent et
différencier en fonction des seniors
s'il y a une réelle volonté des
entreprises d'aller dans dans cette
politique des seniors donc je demanderai
olivierno de retirer son amendement en
attendant ces discussions négociations
même je dirais avec les partenaires
sociaux
sur le ministre
merci monsieur le Président encore une
fois moi j'entends l'intention et on est
tous là pour évidemment chercher des
mesures pour favoriser l'emploi des
seniors mais j'ai eu l'occasion de dire
à l'occasion de la présentation de
l'amendement sur le CDI senior que je
suis réservé notamment sur les
exonérations de cotisation qui sont
liées à un âge donné là en l'occurrence
c'est 57 ans on voit bien que le risque
c'est que ça décale entre guillemets le
problème et qu'un salarié de 55 56 ans
qui se présente dans une entreprise
l'entreprise du dise bah revenez dans un
an ou dans deux ans puisque vous aurez
57 ans et à ce moment-là vous donnerez
droit à une exonération et donc le
salarié en question il se retrouve à
devoir attendre et il aura des
difficultés à trouver un emploi avant
d'atteindre 57 ans par ailleurs c'est
vrai que ça aurait un coût certain
chiffré à 3 milliards 6 avec cet
amendement mais je pense que à travers
votre amendement vous voulez surtout
entre guillemets alerter et provoquer la
discussion sur des mesures sur l'emploi
des seniors et ça me permet de vous
répondre sur le fait que mon collègue
Olivier du socle très entra bien au
printemps prochain la loi travail et que
le sujet de l'emploi des seniors fera
évidemment partie des travaux que vous
conduirez dans le cadre de ce texte
merci Monsieur Hainaut
donc il est retiré
on continue avec l'amendement 124
oui merci monsieur le Président c'est
amendement de ma collègue Dominique
Estrosi Sassone propose d'exonérer de
cotisations vieillesse à la charge de
l'employeur la rémunération versée aux
salariés qui font le choix de continuer
de travailler dès lors qu'ils ont sont
en droit de liquider leur retraite parce
qu'on peut très bien faire le choix de
continuer de travailler malgré le fait
qu'on est passé l'âge de liquider ses
droits à la retraite ça peut être bon
pour le salarié dans son épanouissement
personnel mais ça peut être bon pour
l'entreprise à la fois pour un tuilage
ou à la fois pour pouvoir sauvegarder
une continuité dans l'activité il est à
la fois un outil pour accompagner
certaines fin de carrière et une
incitation pour les employeurs à
recruter les seniors avec une baisse du
coût de travail il favorise également la
transition entre l'emploi et la retraite
pour des salariés qui ne souhaitent pas
partir dès lors qu'ils le peuvent
et enfin en exonérant de ses cotisations
les salariés seniors l'emploi sera
stimulé au sein des entreprises et il
travaille
permettant de créer d'éventuelles
embauches avec les économies réalisées
merci merci Monsieur Ritman monsieur le
rapporteur
oui merci Monsieur Ritman j'ai été très
intéressé par cet amendement et nous
avons essayé de travailler dessus pour
voir comment on pouvait effectivement le
traduire il pose véritablement un effet
de seuil lui aussi selon l'âge et
surtout un effet domaine parce que ceux
qui sont des gens en emploi pourraient
effectivement bénéficier de cette
exonération contenu de la déclaration de
la personne qui part en retraite mais si
elle revient derrière le départ en leur
retraite actuellement n'est pas une
norme législative donc on peut pas
s'appuyer dessus c'est la raison pour
laquelle on appartenu sinon c'est un
effet d'aubaine sinon c'est un effet
domaine c'est pour ça que je vous
demanderai le retirer mais nous avions
songé à la commission justement pour
avoir une cohérence dans nos mesures par
rapport à la surcote que nous accordions
au maire de famille il lui était
intéressant pour celles qui veulent
rester aussi au travail et justement
acquérir
améliorer encore leur futur retraite
qu'elle puisse bénéficier de que
l'employeur puisse bénéficier d'une
exonération pour l'inciter à continuer
justement un petit peu au travail mais
on ne peut pas s'appliquer sur un
dispositif législatif on peut pas créer
comme ça parce que c'est pas une norme
en conséquence ça mérite une réflexion
venant à la fois du ministère et des
partenaires sociaux là aussi on renvoie
à la loi travail donc merci de retirer
l'amendement monsieur le ministre
à nouveau je remercie Monsieur Ritman et
Madame Estrosi Sassone qui est la
première signataire de de la maman c'est
un débat absolument majeur je m'inscris
dans ce cas dit le rapporteur d'un point
de vue juridique j'ajoute aussi qu'il y
a un certain coût qui adore et déjà
aujourd'hui des exonérations générales
qui bénéficient au Seigneur jusqu'à 2,5
SMIC avec le les allègement généraux et
le bandeau maladie et même jusqu'à 3,5
SMIC avec le bandeau famille et que donc
ces exonérations supplémentaires sera
confortés ça serait concentré finalement
sur un petit nombre de seniors ceux qui
ont la rémunération la plus importante
et je suis pas sûr que pour eux la
question de l'exonération de cotisation
soit le moteur principal dans le
recrutement mais ça fera partie des
sujets qui seront abordés à l'occasion
de la loi travail
il est retiré merci
amendement 4639 madame chilinger
alors que le taux d'emploi des seigneurs
en France reste inférieurs à celui de la
moyenne européenne le report de l'âge
légal de départ à la retraite implique
un risque de précarisation des
travailleurs de plus de 55 ans ce risque
pèse particulièrement sur les femmes qui
sont plus sujettes aux carrières hachées
et de ce fait plus exposé au risque de
ne pas pouvoir justifier de l'ensemble
de leur trimestre au moment de leur
départ à la retraite en conséquence le
reportage légal doit s'accompagner de
mesures sociales fortes en faveur de
l'emploi des seniors aussi l'amendement
proposé vise à favoriser l'embauche et
ça allait de plus de 55 ans via
l'allongement des cotisations sociales
relatives à l'assurance vieillesse
merci monsieur le rapporteur
oui effectivement merci d'avoir proposé
cet amendement mais alors dans le groupe
majoritaire je pensais que vous étiez
sensible au rendement de l'équilibre de
cette réforme des retraites parce que
nous c'est l'argument qu'on nous met
sans cesse en face des propositions que
l'on fait donc le but de la réforme
étant de combler les déficits et pas les
creuser je pense que si nous avons une
largesse d'allant jusque 55 ans Monsieur
le Ministre des comptes publics va
tombé du fauteuil en conséquence je vous
demande de retirer l'amendement sachant
que il y a d'autres dispositifs qui
permettent de maintenir les emplois
enseignants et que là effectivement les
exonérations je peux partage toute la
feuille bien entendu le raisonnement
monsieur le ministre porterait surtout
pour les salaires les plus élevés par
rapport au salaire les plus bas qui sont
déjà tournés par les exonérations merci
de le retirer sur le ministre
oui merci monsieur le Président je
rassurais le rapporteur madame chilinger
me fera jamais tomber du fauteuil on est
évidemment bien accroché avec elle je
veux la remercier je vous remercie
madame la sénatrice pour là aussi
contribuer au débat sur cette question
de l'emploi des seniors qui est
absolument majeur moi je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure je suis réservé sur les
exonérations de cotisation qui sont
liées à un âge donné puisque le risque
c'est qu'il y a un effet de seuil et que
ceux qui sont juste en dessous de l'âge
se retrouvent entre guillemets les ai
par ailleurs c'est vrai qu'il y a un
certain coût un point de baisse de
cotisation c'est un milliard donc là
votre amendement ne fixe pas le nombre
de points de baisse qui renvoie un
décret mais enfin c'est un coup certain
pour un effet plus incertain sur
l'emploi mais je vous remercie d'avoir
porté le débat qui se produira qui se
prolongera dans la loi travail donc je
propose le retrait de l'amendement
le but c'était vraiment de d'évoquer ce
sujet là merci donc il est retiré
ensuite deux amendements en discussion
commune le 3150 4 madame ponce
c'est un effet de substitution
d'augmentation des
un simple effet de substitution ce qu'on
appelle aussi un effet d'aubaine mais
les salariés justement sont en train de
faire le lien entre la cotisation et les
droits et c'est très bien qu'il le fasse
parce que ce salaire socialisé dont vous
leur faites cadeaux enfin en disant que
vous les taxez pas paraît-il et bien
c'est une perte de recettes pour la
protection sociale d'autant quand elles
sont pas compensées c'est le cas ici et
quelque part vous leur présentez la
facture c'est quelques mois de travail
en plus puisque vous asséchez des
recettes et donc vous ferez déficit
quant aux salariés lui aussi il vient de
s'apercevoir aussi que de ne pas avoir
ce salaire socialisé c'est un cadeau à
court terme mais une perte à long terme
parce que tout comme les fonctionnaires
il s'aperçoivent que les primes des
socialisés et des fonctionné et des
fiscalisés ne compte pas dans la pension
et participent à la baisse tendancielle
des pensions donc voilà tous voulons
remettre dans l'application du droit
c'est terminé madame c'est terminé merci
président
le 4475 monsieur Baki merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur les ministres cet
amendement pointe le double discours du
gouvernement qui prétend vouloir à la
fois sauver le régime répartition ou
empêcher la faillite du système mais en
même temps qui s'attache à chaque
occasion à soustraire aux cotisations
les éléments de rémunération octroyés
aux travailleurs les mesures nouvelles
récemment prises n'auraient pas d'impact
sur les recettes de la sécurité sociale
nous le disons le principe c'est que
tout travail mérite salaire et toute
cotisations et du salaire par ce
postulat les heures supplémentaires
coûteraient 200 millions d'euros en
année pleine en 2023 mais la
monétisation des RTT qui procède de la
même finalité serait elle sans impact
financier selon le même raisonnement la
prime Macron mal nommé partage de la
valeur
car désocialiser ne pèserait sur les
finances de la sécurité sociale elle
constitue par nature mais par nature
pardonne l'effet d'éviction du salaire
et devrait de ce fait se voir appliquer
le taux de cotisation par défaut
appliqué à chaque tranche de salaire
pour calculer le manque à gagner de
cette forme de rémunération au détriment
du salaire ne propagez pas monsieur le
ministre l'idée que les cotisations sont
sous tirées aux travailleurs et qu'elle
est prise de revenus les cotisations
sont du salaire partageons la valeur en
entier jusqu'au moindre euro en somme
soumettons aux cotisations chaque euro
versé aux travailleuses et aux
travailleurs
merci donc sur ces deux amendements la
vie de Madame la rapporteur oui ces deux
amendements proposent finalement de
vider de son contenu le dispositif de de
comment de prime de partage de la valeur
de la valeur qui a été je le rappelle
mis en place assez récemment finalement
puisque ça date du 22 août dernier
en réalité et bien on ne prendrait pas
en considération le nombre d'entreprises
et le nombre de salariés dont on vient
de parler monsieur de ministre qui
bénéficie de cette prime si à certains
tel succès c'est bien que actuellement
c'est un plus pour un certain nombre de
salariés mais aussi pour de familles
donc c'est un avis défavorable
sur le ministre
merci monsieur le Président en fait ce
sont des amendements qui visent à mettre
fin à la prime de partage de la valeur
ou à la prime Macron
puisque si vous et c'est ce que propose
ces amendements si vous leur appliquez
le même niveau le niveau de cotisation
sociale général auranement ça veut dire
que vous mettez en place un niveau de
cotisation sociale jusqu'à 60 points
et donc pour une prime à 1000 euros qui
est versé par l'entreprise à un salarié
ça veut dire qu'il faut payer 600 euros
jusqu'à 600 euros de cotisation autant
dire qu'il y a plus de primes moi je
rappelle quand même que cette prime l'an
dernier elle a bénéficié à 5 millions
500 000 salariés 4 milliards 500
millions d'euros qui ont été partagés
avec 5 millions salariés dont 2 millions
dans des entreprises de moins de 50
salariés et les primes les plus
importantes étaient dans les TPE donc
c'est pas pour des cadres des grands
groupes les primes les plus importantes
étaient dans des TPE vous dites le
versement de ces primes défiscalisés des
socialisés se fait au détriment du
financement de la protection sociale je
suis pas d'accord avec ça parce que
c'est des outils qui sont précisément
mis à la disposition d'entreprises qui
en raison de l'incertitude économique ne
peuvent pas augmenter les salaires parce
qu'elles s'engagerait sur des charges
supplémentaires pour les années à venir
sans savoir ce que sera la situation
économique et donc il précisément
peuvent donner une prime à des salariés
donc c'est pas la prime ou du salaire
c'est bien souvent la ou rien et donc ça
ne se fait pas au détriment du
financement de la protection sociale ça
ne se fait qu'au bénéfice de la
rémunération du salarié de son pouvoir
d'achat donc avis défavorable
aucun double avis défavorable monsieur
gay
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues merci de
ces chiffres monsieur monsieur le
ministre c'est un million de salariés en
moyenne 800 euros je crois 789 en
moyenne donc ça veut dire que 1 il y
avait pas besoin d'une loi cet été pour
doubler le plafond parce que le plafond
était déjà 1000 euros donc 2000 on voit
que ça a réagi non mais non mais c'est
ça la réalité monsieur monsieur le
ministre deuxièmement 5 millions de
salariés certes mais il y en a combien
en France plus de 26 millions
c'est-à-dire que 18% des salariés
touchent ce qu'on appelle la prime de la
partage ou la prime Macron peu importe
et 82% des salariés ils ont touché quoi
ben pas grand chose
donc la question de l'augmentation des
salaires elle est bien posée pour
l'ensemble des salariés y compris ceux
qui ont touché la prime Macron et donc
la question
on voit bien c'est un détournement et
certains pour éviter d'augmenter les
salaires on fait cela pour 18% des
salariés c'est mieux de le dire comme ça
que c'est un million on a l'impression
que quand vous dites 5 millions tout le
monde l'a touché revenons aussi 18% des
salariés l'ont touché 82 % donc n'aurait
rien touché parce qu'on n'a pas vu une
augmentation massive des salaires en
France sauf là où il y a eu des luttes
et à chaque fois ça a payé donc vous
avez une question autour du salaire et
autour évidemment du salaire brut et net
et de la part brut du salaire socialisé
qui lui irrigue les caisses de la
Sécurité sociale ce que ne fait pas la
prime Macron et si on continue à ce que
l'ensemble aujourd'hui des négociations
des NAO tourne autour c'est la prime ou
rien
nous même nous allons assécher en
réalité les caisses de la Sécurité
sociale voilà le principe mais
évidemment c'est les ceux qui l'ont
touché on leur a pas dit ne la prenez
pas prenez ayez des négociations sur
l'augmentation des salaires monsieur
broyer
merci monsieur le Président oui là en
fait la question c'est effectivement
comment ne pas affaiblir les contes de
la sécurité sociale par ces mesures
alors on avait au moment de du débat en
loi de finance un excellent amendement
au nom de la commission des affaires
sociales de la rapporteur madame Doineau
qui avait pour objet de rejeter le
principe de non-compensation à la
sécurité sociale du coût de la prime de
partage de la valeur que le gouvernement
a inséré subrepticement en intégrant un
amendement dans le texte considéré comme
adopté par l'Assemblée nationale sur
lequel les députés n'ont donc pas pu se
prononcer et je crois que c'était
effectivement une sagesse de notre
assemblée qui avait voté cet amendement
et qui mériterait donc d'être réinstallé
et qu'on arrête de dépouiller la
sécurité sociale
merci donc sur ces deux amendements nous
avons double avis défavorable je vais
les soumettre aux voix le premier donc
présenté par madame poncemont je le 3150
4 qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient n'est pas adopté le
deuxième
4475 présenté par Monsieur Baki qui est
pour
qui contre
qui s'abstient et n'est pas adopté nous
passons à l'article 2 bis
et nous avons plusieurs demandes de
prise de parole sur cet article la
première